Australia to salute my brother.
A little brother.
Yeah.
Does it feel like I'm going to show time special?
I don't know.
I feel the same.
Little more stressed out.
Stressed out.
Yeah.
Stay away from them.
Comments on these,
the whole deal with all that stuff,
man.
He put it out.
You Watch it,
you hate it.
You get better forces.
You forces you to work.
I fucking hate everything I do.
There's just no getting around it.
You're going to hate it.
You hate hearing yourself.
The editing is powerful,
man.
Delaware first,
but you'll get better.
You just take the,
some of the criticism to heart.
Understand what people were saying.
Four shares.
Just a fucking keep on keeping on my brother.
I'm happy about it.
I just,
I,
I don't think I'm stressed out this week.
He's lasts because doing publicity for it like New York and doing all that.
Yeah.
I saw you did breakfast club.
Charlemagne and Charlemagne needed to get together.
You guys would be great man.
I was listening to his,
um,
his audio book.
It's very interesting.
He's had,
he's said some real bouts with anxiety.
Yeah.
Weird,
weird anxiety.
Yeah.
Where it anxiety,
right.
Shook ones,
I think.
Yeah.
I think it comes from talking shit.
I think when you talk a lot of Shit,
you worry about shit coming back at you and you're like,
Jesus,
what did I say?
At least that's how it is for me.
It depends if it's like legit,
like when me and Dana were going out.
Oh,
you're stressed.
Yeah.
I just don't want that name because it,
because it brings out like the course evilness and people,
you know,
everyone's like,
oh,
I hope he tears him up.
Oh,
I hope we respond in.
Yeah.
And then you're like,
oh,
I don't,
I don't really want this.
Do you see Gaffigan and Neil and Neil Brennan?
No.
Do no way.
Gaffigan lit Neal Brennan on fire.
Shit on his numbers for what?
Neil started it.
Why?
And he'll start it.
I'm going to,
I'm going to send it to Jamie.
I'm so in my sober October text message group and listen,
I love Neil
when someone gets roasted,
so I'm going to gets roasted and it's even better because he started it.
He started it for no reason.
Oh No.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I tried to be Narky here.
Jamie,
I'm sending this to you right now.
Jim Gaffigan is a mama.
I'm a monster.
Fantastic.
In Transylvania three Waze.
Oh,
amazing.
I saw that man.
Hell son was hit.
He was van Helsing.
Oh my God.
It's amazing.
Great.
I love those movies are fun.
I love when my son gets into that stuff.
Just fucking animation today is so incredible.
I find myself sitting there watching the animation going,
this is amazing.
The shading and the,
just the detail of it.
He can get into it where it's,
even if it's meant for kids.
As a parent,
I'm good man.
To watch the despicable me's.
Oh yeah.
Great.
That's great.
Peripheries amazing.
All three of them are great,
but I love part three with the 80 soundtrack.
It's not the creative from a south park and isn't there another one with just
the fucking yellow dudes?
The minions.
That's good too.
Yeah,
I saw that one little long towards the end.
It gets a little weird when they get to London,
but very good.
Yeah,
they're good,
man.
That's so funny.
When you,
so this is the text,
Brennan Service.
So,
uh,
what happens is,
Gaffigan
puts up a thing saying,
hey,
why are you looking at your phone?
You can be watching my Netflix special.
I made them all for you.
And he says,
Neil says,
which one has the joke about food?
You say like a food.
And then you talk about it.
And I'd be over here dying.
And then Gavigan says Neil.
It's a special where I have three microphones.
One microphone is for jokes.
I pretend I can't remember that I read off a card.
One Mike is for emotional manipulation of the audience.
And one microphone is for mentioning the Chappelle show and celebrity friends.
Boom.
That's like,
oh,
that's like one of those bombs that goes off in the distance.
Did you see it?
And we're just like this with,
he's got a little frisky.
What app got a little frisky.
Seattle falls guy fired back.
Yep.
Sometimes this guy's fire bad.
A little vulnerable spot right there.
The liver was exposed.
Neil,
just bad out.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you.
Yeah.
You're supposed to bow out there.
You didn't do,
you fucked up.
You supposed to say ouch.
You got me herself to just joking,
man.
Yeah.
Um,
like sometimes one king of the Cynthia and I across each other and he's so good
at it.
Sometimes I'm just like,
I'm gonna sit out,
man.
Go ahead man.
I got nothing.
I've ran out of material deal.
Go ahead.
Some of the things he says are so Theo,
like he,
Theo is like,
there's a few guys,
Theo's one of them.
Sebastian's another one that have the like a style of comedy that you will never
be able to explain to someone.
They got to go see him.
Like you got to listen to him.
Isn't it so strange where most of the kinks thing podcasts is mostly me saying
something pretty average.
And then Theo just saying them up most outlandish thing.
You me laughing my ass off the funniest show.
What did you guys go back and forth at each other?
It's very funny.
So funny man.
Yeah.
He's in a unique dude.
Very unique dude is unique as they get,
he's in Australia right now.
He goes,
yeah,
he's in Australia,
Australian lento right now.
And he goes,
yeah,
this is this morning was,
yeah man,
you got a qual comm.
Come to the hotel.
And I went,
Oh shit man.
Those things have chlamydia,
so make sure you wash your hands.
And he goes,
shit,
I have some things to,
he better wash his hand.
Just like
he better watch his hands.
Oh my God.
But it's legit a clause coming over to the [inaudible] hotel.
That's so Theo Brody was that way too.
Brody had the unique style too.
He's so special,
man.
That deal.
So special is very,
just know it.
Yeah.
You just know it man.
I be,
we're asking what it's like to work with deal.
All you guys.
I said with you,
it's like he's the Lebron James of Cami.
So creative.
I'm just that shitty coach on the side trying to manage,
trying to manage his ball game.
Not to fuck it up,
man.
Yeah,
he's,
but he's just,
I mean there's other guys that are funny,
but they're funny in like a regular way.
Like,
oh,
he's really good.
His jokes are great.
Oh,
he's got a great PR presence.
He's great on stage.
But Theo's like,
try to explain that.
You can't explain that.
You gotta go see magical cluster of dark magic from New Orleans where he'll say
something and I'm like,
there's certain guys I can watch and I'll go,
oh,
he,
he's definitely,
his Iq might be higher than mine,
but I see how he got there with this premise of the joke with Theo.
I'm like,
ah,
I have no idea how he got the I've,
it's not happening.
You know who gives me stress when I look at his schedule?
Russell Peters.
Yeah,
he,
this me and like,
she's all over the fucking pipeline right now.
He goes to Africa for like six weeks.
Like he's all,
you hear Michael Bisping almost got fucking robbed in Africa.
Did he really just doing a movie?
Fuck.
Was he doing in Africa doing a movie and spend was 19.
I don't know what it was,
is doing a movie.
You got a little liquored up.
Uh,
his cab dropped him off and said,
you're a,
your hotels over there.
He'd get out of the cab and he's like,
where are the flux?
My hotel,
the cab driver drives off and he's like looking around for the hotel is,
he said like 10 dudes just started rolling up on them saying,
I want your wallet.
You know,
if you want to live,
you'll give me your wallet.
Yeah.
Is this South Africa or this out?
This is like France in Ghana.
Lisa for Toria.
Fuck man.
So he ran and he got away obviously.
Yeah,
he got away.
Yeah.
But food's always gonna get caught,
right?
Yeah.
Black.
He's a big fella,
you know,
and not seeking this fight.
This fellow knows how to fight and they probably could sense that a little bit,
but if there's 10 of them,
they usually don't probably hammered too.
Been,
what if it was 10 Francis in Ghana?
Oh Geez.
Then you're given your wallet and do just the homies.
Road trips is one Francis and Ghana.
What the fuck you got and do nothing and let the fuck you going to do.
Yeah,
I love them.
Bisbing Maddie hazard was telling me that when he was running he ran like 27
marathons in South Africa and when he went through certain sections of South
Africa they go stop.
You are not running through this area.
We're going to put you in a car.
We're going to drive you towards safe and then you're going to continue to run
but you will get robbed.
Like cause like there's areas where you just,
we'll get rob,
I have no interest in going to Africa and I was like oh it's beautiful.
Very cool.
I want to go you really?
Yeah.
I want to go.
I want to see what those animals look like in the wild.
I would love to see,
you know before we fuck Africa Up,
you've got 12 years.
They say before is everything's gone forward the way humans are fucking up the
world.
There is no going back.
If we don't make a change now.
Now it's from the,
it sounds like a Michael Jackson song
that's from the ending of little Dickies,
new video of saving the world.
But it does say it's like earth.org it's like that's a quote from them.
I don't think they know is.
See the reality is they know there's a real problem with carbon in the
environment.
They know that human beings are put carbon in the environment,
an unprecedented levels and they know that the earth is heating up rapidly,
but they don't know like what exactly is going to happen.
There's some models they predict,
none of them look good.
They don't really know.
But th really knows,
right?
Like some people are like ah,
global warming side Brielle ups.
Our president think it is.
It's real.
But if you go back to like the 1990s they were predicting shit was going to
happen.
That never happened.
Same thing with the two thousands but here we are in 2019 we're,
you know,
we should listen to them because we're definitely fuck it up.
Don't be fucking up the mix either whales and stuff with like trash in the
stomach and that's hurt.
That's a giant problem.
There's also too many people,
but what are you going to do?
Well,
there's two schools of thought on that.
Even the schools of thought on people is what happens is as the world gets more
and more Westernized,
as people start developing careers,
people have less and less kids and that if you look at Japan and you look at
some westernized nations,
they actually have a shortage of kids and they,
they think that,
and this is purely speculative,
right?
It's just theoretical.
They think that as the world becomes more and more industrialized in Western
eyes and more technology and more advanced,
that people will start to have less kids.
That's a fair point.
But also even Americans,
they're having kids later and I think less as well.
Yeah,
that's a mic.
But also isn't there parts of Australia and Africa where no one's really there.
So if we had to,
we could colonize that and like make it more livable,
bro.
The only parts of Australia where no one lives,
no one wants to live.
You don't want to live in the fucking metal.
All the crocodiles are in shit,
but we could figure it out.
Yeah,
you could figure it out.
A couple of crocs field a lot of snakes everywhere.
That'll kill you.
I mean there's a lot of parts of Austria.
Australia is huge.
It's as big as the United States,
so big and that giant parts.
Africa,
two giant parts where we could live if we had that.
Australia has less people than La.
No,
the whole goddamn country.
You've been there,
right?
Yeah.
Bunch.
I love it.
Love it.
[inaudible] I'm sure you've done comedy.
Yeah,
a bunch of times.
The best.
Yeah.
Sydney,
Melbourne and Melbourne's grade need to though.
I have a great time that I've been to New Zealand.
Yeah.
No,
I've never been hurt to aim straight off of Jurassic Park.
Would you do their comedy?
No.
Shit.
Theater in New Zealand.
When did you do this?
I think like a year and a half.
Two years ago I did a tour of Australia and that's when you would adjust
starting to,
that's crazy.
This out.
No openers came out cold.
Oh my God.
Why did you do that?
I don't crazy.
No one.
Hey Man,
I show a showcase on night and go to Australia and just go by yourself.
Then he didn't even ask.
I just sweat dude.
Here I am.
Show time session.
It was fun though.
Good expanses.
Oh,
they're good people.
I liked the people.
Everybody I met from New Zealand.
It's like very similar to Australian people.
Very down to earth.
Super Nice.
Yeah.
It's a beautiful place man.
Means they did the hobbit there for a fucking reason.
Yeah.
Good point.
Good food.
Good people.
Yeah.
I could,
not that I could ever leave la,
but I could see I could live somewhere like I could live in Australia.
Me Too.
It's very American,
but clean and feel like.
Yeah,
but that's the driving on the wrong side of the road.
Shit like get it together folks.
We invented cars.
The fuck are you doing over there in the left lane.
That is strange.
Do you know where that came from?
Yeah.
No,
correct me.
Okay.
This is bro Science.
But when they were developing,
uh,
it was the,
like the,
the wagons with the horses is Fort Sword Fighting,
right?
Yeah.
For horses and sword fighting.
Yes.
You got it.
Yeah.
That's why you swing a sword with your right arm.
You want your right arm to be facing your opponent.
So you want,
yeah,
you don't want to the dude to be over here on this side,
reach over and try to hack does make sense.
But here's,
here's a,
here's a little,
a loophole.
Like if you want a dope ass,
like rare car,
you can get one with driving on the right and it's gonna be cheaper.
So if you want like a Ferrari f 12 TDF,
like a limited one,
you can save money if you get one that set up on the right because they're set
up on the right,
like an English course because they're harder to resell because there's less,
less people just throw them away.
Oh,
come on.
But you could just drive on the right who you're still in the doe fashion.
That,
can they switch it out?
Uh,
be expensive.
Probably just buy it on the other side from agile.
Like what are they gonna do?
Switch it out.
They'd have to change everything at debt nightmare.
I saw they did that to this rev ology car,
this 1965 Mustang.
They built one that was on the right hand drive and I'm looking at it,
I'm like,
this is all so screwy.
Like why would they do,
why would people not come to an agreement on which side of the road to drive on?
It's very strange that you stick with it.
Yeah.
And it's different.
Differs from like in Europe,
it differs from country to country.
Yeah.
It's almost an ego thing now,
right?
Where they're like,
Nah,
fuck it.
Refuse to change.
Most of the world's on the left though,
man.
We don't care.
Well,
Germany makes the best cars or some of the best cars.
They're on the left Europe.
It's the best cars and they're on the left,
right?
Yeah.
American makes some pretty good cars,
but really the reality is they can't go toe to toe with Europe.
They just can't.
Dude,
I was a,
I was at this private car dealer and there's those,
uh,
Pagani says,
have you ever seen those?
Like a million dollar car,
right.
Some of them are,
you know,
you're looking six,
$7 million put for Donnie's.
There's Bugattis that,
that the,
the rear brand new Bugatti.
And then there's all these limited dish and Ferrari's and Lamborghini's.
And he goes,
oh,
Floyd bought that one.
You can sit in it though.
He won't kill you.
And Senate.
And there's all like carbon fiber nodes of how much is it and whatever the new
boot God is.
But there's a markup on them because they were like 20 of them.
Where the fuck it is.
And it was so expensive.
I got nervous.
I'm it.
I'm good man.
Here's you don't to say and what not.
I don't feel comfortable.
I'm good.
I just didn't feel comfortable open this thing.
I don't know.
I felt variable million dollars.
So yeah,
you could buy a car that's worth more than most people's houses.
99% of the world's houses.
Yeah.
99.9% of the world's house.
And you're just working that thing around and you just driving around in this
thing that you can sleep in and then most toilet,
he can't do shit and shower.
Try Fastest Shit.
Drive faster.
Shit.
25 g's.
Just changed the tires though.
Is it really?
Yeah.
Every year.
That's all if you're driving it,
but I'll sit right here.
Sorry.
Do you see how it's hurting?
Five scratching.
Go back to the beginning of that video.
Look at on your side,
the underside of the things Jack.
And that's all carbon fiber.
So he scratched the fuck out of it,
man.
Yeah.
Wow.
Those cars,
they scratch every time you hit a bump,
every time you go over curbs and that they're so low.
Jamie.
That's,
I mean,
that's when I have my little red car,
the Little Red Porsche.
Every time I leave the comedy store,
it's scrape.
It's embarrassing.
It's annoying.
And it's so sad.
Sad.
I didn't mind another days taking my dad to get ice cream and I hit the front of
my car.
Caray ruin my night,
ruminate,
my Niggas,
it,
I don't give a fuck to him.
I was so disappointed.
I was sad.
I know it's just a car though,
right?
It is just a car.
It's the problem with nice things.
They've become a little velvet prisons but you got to drive him like uh,
the dealer I was talking to were where all these fricking dudes by these million
dollar cars.
He's like,
you know what bothers me is they don't drive them.
None of them drive them.
It's for them.
It's investment and then they flip in years from now he was,
we want people that drive the cars and now what frog is doing.
Like if you want to end though,
you want a certain like limited run TDF or the pizza.
If you want some of those real limited edition ones,
they look at your history cause you have to own like the past 10 Ferrari's.
Yeah they have a weird curriculum if you want to get a special limited edition.
But they now they check if you've driven it,
if you're just a collector they don't sell them to you anymore.
Oh my gosh.
Certain ones they go back and look at your history cause you got to do it own
all the old Ferrari's to qualify to buy a Ferrari certain fries sir to take get
on that accolation like the on the list,
let's say if you want to,
if you want like the new whatever the super fast,
the limited TDF they're going to do.
Yeah.
You have to own all the V twelves and certain ones before that.
That is hilarious because that just shows you how goofy people are.
Like they,
they know that people are goofy and they know that all you have to do is like
sneaking on them some sort of exclusive thing that nobody else can have.
So when you row up in it,
you look like a champ and no one else does.
Yeah.
Even if it sucks,
even if it's a sucky car.
No,
I like it though because some,
let's say some billionaire rich billionaire who daddy gave him all his money,
he can't roll into frame bike.
I'll take that.
That's kind of cool.
I mean now it's a little extreme with the 10 and you've got to own all the V
twelves but what do you mean that they can suck it?
You don't like it?
No,
because you can't.
Well,
you probably,
I don't know.
Who knows if I could get used though.
That's the thing you just buy using.
Yeah.
All right,
cool dude.
Yeah,
flux.
Get a buy it now.
She get it from him and not going to stop it.
It's like illegal streaming.
You guys are just dumb business people.
How about you make more cars stupid?
Well,
no you don't.
No.
You don't want to become a Tesla Prius.
How could they say?
How much can they sell?
How many are they leaving on the table?
Think about it that way.
I don't think they care.
Right?
How many people,
how many people are buying Ferrari's?
Let's just take a guess.
Let's just say worldwide 100,000 people are buying for ours.
Maybe it'd be 200,000 maybe if they just started being twats to be 200,000
Ferrari's out there instead of 100,000 I don't think they want that though.
If everyone can have it.
You don't want it.
Right.
That's just weird,
man.
Girls are that way with purses.
You ever talked to girls about certain verses?
Sure.
To get weird about purses.
So hard to get that prayer.
I'm like that with shoes though.
I don't want them to have shoes that pairs.
You're kind of like that when you're not going to be,
you're kind of like that in my background with your custom cars,
like one of the reasons that make it really cool
is you're not going to see that custom car anywhere else that is specifically
designed by you.
That's true.
But that's not why I like it.
Well I like it is cause you could get something that you can't get anywhere else
putting on on me.
And as far as performance,
like,
like when I get the like a shark quirks car,
like the white car,
that car,
you can't,
it can't just get that car.
It's a six speed manual.
They don't make six speed manual gt three Rs is anymore.
It has a 518 horsepower engine.
You can get that.
They bought it out.
They put fatter tires in it.
They beefed up the suspension,
they changed everything for sure.
But like your resorts.
Yeah.
Okay.
It's pretty custom.
Can't buy those camp by him.
Right.
But honestly,
I'm for Joe.
That car is like,
that's a cool looking car.
Ellyette is,
but if you had a drive that every day,
you'd probably blow your fucking brains out unless you're one of those renegade
dudes.
Let's just start.
Lorenzo Lamas back in the day wore cowboy boots.
Dustin,
his hair,
I feel like [inaudible] every day.
At the end of 2017 the total of Ferrari built and sold cars in the whole
company.
History is 109 nine thousand two hundred thousand ever.
You said 200,000 a year,
but your close.
Wow.
I was way off.
It's eight to 10,000 a year.
It looks like I want to just read some dope.
That's why it's so hard to get one.
Yes.
Yeah.
It's kind of cool.
Look,
it is definitely cool.
It's a,
it's a cool car.
I mean,
this is a reason why people want them.
They don't want shitty cars.
No,
they're good car.
I wouldn't mind.
They do.
There's a,
I think it's a four or maybe it's a,
I don't know if it's a four eight but they did make that in manual.
What I like too expensive.
What I like about like custom cars is that their mechanical,
like when I'm talking about like muscle cars or portions or stuff like that.
What I like is that they're mechanical,
they're all stick shifts,
manual transmissions,
feel the gears and you feel the burn.
I like that.
I love that.
Yeah.
I'm that's,
I'm into that for whatever reason,
but I'm also into that fucking Tesla that Tesla's got me hooked.
Yeah,
for sure.
I think it puts a smile on my face.
I know you does it really?
Oh my God.
So then when you were Porsches?
Nope.
Not more.
So it's going to lock in different smile.
Different smiles.
Yeah.
It's like wow.
The future's weird.
Yeah,
because it's just,
it doesn't make so much more capable.
No,
no,
no.
It's not for Roche's.
Yep.
And Ferrari's ferocious.
Wow.
That noise.
The engine explosions behind your ear.
Mid Engine car,
that's a different thing.
Like a muscle car that rumbled at fucking big Ass v eight and a fat tail pipes.
That's a different feel,
you know?
Completely different.
Yeah.
What'd you get from a Tesla is like,
whoa,
every other car just seems stupid.
It's like you just making a lot of noise but it just,
this thing just goes quicker.
It goes places it like with the Tesla does it violates what you think the laws
of driving on in terms of like how quicker car can get from there to there and
it doesn't with no sound,
there's no torque or anything.
Right.
It's just zero.
It's just said a thousand foot pounds of Toyotas and it just like it's a video
game throws you back like the craziest roller coaster you've ever been in.
Yeah,
because zero to 60 in 2.4 seconds you have the ludicrous one.
Yeah.
That's all.
I always leave it on.
Ludicrous.
Yeah.
I never switched off that shit way too.
Why would I?
Yeah.
I don't drive it.
You don't have to drive it like an asshole,
but when you want to,
it's right there.
It's using up more of the,
Oh yeah.
AIDS,
that battery kid.
If you want to drive,
what do they say?
Kids 317 miles.
Mile like grandma drive.
Yeah,
and they're like,
daddy drives,
it gets like one seven,
three,
one 72 way I drive.
They were saying that,
uh,
people applying for a driver's license,
so she,
kids like our kids,
I don't know if they'd even be into cars.
Like I was talking to my dad.
I went,
how cool is it?
Like Tigers has all,
he's been on all these cool cars.
Hopefully he's into cars when he gets older.
And my dad's like,
yeah,
maybe if he even wants to driver license is now,
it's so low of kids passing the driver's license test because they just Uber
everywhere.
It's like,
why?
What?
Why do I pay for a car?
I'm just gonna do some great thing that you don't have to think about like that.
That does help a lot.
Like you don't think about drunk being drunk,
driving drunk,
you know,
going to someone's house after the bar.
It's cool to option,
but it's not cool that kids,
there's something,
there's some freedom about driving,
like there's a good feeling to it.
There's also the problem with things like Uber is you're going to get into a car
with a person that you don't know,
and I'm sure most of them are great,
I'm sure.
But every now and then you're going to get into a car with someone who's fucking
nuts and they're going to have some crazy political podcast on want to talk to
you about Hillary Clinton's emails an option now you know that.
Yeah,
you can click the,
they don't talk to you.
Do you want them to talk?
No,
that's a new option they're doing.
They don't have to abide by it.
I don't think it's like a preference for the variety.
Like,
Hey,
by the way,
as I get in your car,
I really would prefer you.
Don't talk to me.
But the driver is like,
you're in my car.
Fuck you up.
Yeah.
But most drivers you might go,
he clicked.
Don't talk if he's like,
hey,
I'd like,
dude,
did you see the known talk or yeah,
the move is,
hey,
you got music up there.
Can you turn it up?
Then they usually don't talk,
but there has been a thing,
to your point where there's been people,
you know,
faking,
like duper drives,
putting the sign on.
Then murdering women.
There's that.
Yeah,
there has been that.
I heard about that recently.
Do you like,
I've been in this and I've been having terrible dreams.
I need to get off of it or just figure out how to deal with manage it better.
But I was doing a show on Sirius with Jim Norton and he brought in this,
the guy who basically created mine,
hunter.
He was this like,
he's interviewed all the serial killers and speaks to them and they brought him
in,
I think his name is John Douglas.
They brought him in.
He used to talking to,
it was fascinating.
I was like,
Oh shit.
So I got his book,
almost finished his book.
I'm like,
this is great man.
And then started listening to a podcast he's on,
it's just about like murder and death.
And I started looking up all this Charles Manson stuff that I'd been having
awful nightmares and been a little depressed.
And you know me,
I'm,
it's very rare.
I'm down.
It's just a dark fucking world man.
Yeah.
You Watch those true crime shows will fuck your head up dude and makes you
scared of everything going on.
It's going on in very small numbers,
very,
very small numbers.
But it is going on.
What it is is like people that have been abused,
people that have been fucked up,
psychopaths and people that have been through the correction system through,
through the penal system.
Yeah.
That's a lot of it's so dark men is not that many of them.
And this,
this guy has a three daughters and I was like,
how can you like keeps telling about this seven year old,
terrible story.
And uh,
I was like,
how can you go home and sleep?
He's like,
eventually,
you know,
it's just a job.
Like it does affect me a little bit.
And I'm like,
do you just lock up your kids?
Like I'd be like,
just from hearing you,
I don't want my son going to school.
I don't want,
I'm leaving.
He's like,
now you learn to manage it.
And he did say that.
He's like that.
This is the exception.
Like there's some dark stuff out there,
but these gentlemen that he interviewed,
Charles Manson,
you've seen how he's five too,
and he always has to speak over you no matter what's going on.
So they were in this room,
there's three people and Charles Manson,
he got on a chair and stood over him,
shouted down to him.
Was he saying I didn't pry,
try and convert them into a home.
He people who may meet your car.
Meech man,
man,
I'm a product of your society,
man.
He's fucking crazy.
He was crazy.
He had to close down.
He has a quote.
Does reading again,
I'm too into it.
Men.
I'm quoting Charles Manson,
what's going on in my life?
Um,
he was saying that,
uh,
he used to be like,
you are the exception when you're crazy.
Now everybody's crazy.
That's what Manson was like.
Yeah.
He's like used to be kind of cool.
The end thing to be crazy.
Now inside everybody's crazy.
Well he made it popular.
The fuck.
Do you know how popular that fucking crazy serial killer is and all his
followers?
Oh my God.
Even to this day,
like as I was reading this article in rolling stones,
how many books and even merge and buy lots of his,
here's 50 grand.
It's going for 50 grand by locks of his hair and how he sells merge.
That's 50 grand of locks of his hair.
Yeah.
How much does a lock,
like what does that mean?
What does that get you?
I don't know.
Well you could.
I lost out on the,
I lost out on the bid.
Cut a lock in half.
You know what I'm saying?
Let's,
I'm going to say how many go?
Let's split it.
Put it in his essay.
How many hairs block?
Big piece though.
What if he shaves his balls and you give like a Saran wrap Baggie of his pubes.
How much does that weigh?
100 gs piece of is probably Dick pays a hundred gs.
Charles Manson,
Dick piece.
He was married when he died.
Some the crazy bitches find serial killers in jail and marry them.
Happened with Richard Ramirez,
the night stalker,
if there's some sexual thing too,
right?
Yeah.
They,
some women want to be around killers and even in particular guys have killed
women.
How?
How crazy is that?
It's very crazy.
Can you imagine when your daughters,
when they're,
let's say 20 to Mary's,
a serial killer in prison leash,
you know,
she's not gonna die but safe.
Look,
there's people out there.
I don't have to tell you,
I do a fucking terrible job of raising their kids.
You know?
It's one of the reasons why people like you,
people like me,
people that get into being a parent that really enjoy it.
When you see something like that,
it's even more disturbing because you know that when you see a serial killer or
someone's fucked up,
that person was a baby that had a terrible life.
Like almost always.
They just got a shitty roll.
The dice,
they got bad parents.
It's usually the moms.
It's a relationship with the moms that fucked him up.
Not so much.
The father's usually them.
It's um,
the mother son relationship.
Really?
Yeah.
It's usually always mother's son and that's what usually causes the whole swine
Norman Bates from psycho.
So,
so dead on,
right?
Yep.
And he's dealing with his mom and dress up like his mom's and that guy and he's
the one who literally,
he's Jeffrey Dahmer.
Charles Manson.
It when there's something go like,
uh,
he was talking about Jon Benet,
which,
you know,
I'm from Denver,
went to school in Boulder.
That was the Jon Benet Ramsey murder case was such a big deal and still can't
sell that house.
They can't,
they can't sell it.
And I had a buddy,
my strength coach,
a.
Dot crease rented it.
It was like,
ah,
fuck it ghost and moved in there like right after the murders.
Anyway,
so,
uh,
the uh,
handle it,
the freak out now he's cool.
He's from Louisiana.
Like real tough dude.
Didn't give a fuck.
They're missing a chromosome down there.
Yeah.
You gotta be pretty crazy to move in there even though it was a great deal and
is a great spot.
But home was for sale for years,
for years.
I knocked it down.
They should,
I drove to the Oj Simpson should knock it down.
They should take out all the dirt and replace it with new dirt.
Yeah,
they should be doing everything.
Does knock it down and dig a hole all the way to hell.
Whenever the fuck dirt was,
they're so dirty man.
But um,
that dude,
he was just talking,
talking and it was fascinating.
I didn't say a word and then went into Jon Benet.
I'm like,
Ooh,
I'm going to chime in here cause I know this case and I know it well.
And Jim asked him a question that was like,
my time to jump in.
I go,
yeah,
but yeah,
but it's probably the parents.
Right?
Or maybe the sun.
And he hasn't acknowledged me this entire interview.
I don't know if Jim remember noted this.
And he goes,
what'd you say it was?
And I could tell I fucked up.
I go,
this is probably the parents or the sun,
right.
And he goes,
absolutely not.
Absolutely not.
Brendan.
And then goes on how ridiculous they have an assumption that is,
and I go,
well,
but who does he think did it?
Uh,
he was,
it's not them.
He any and he goes,
you,
the promise is the narrative that got painted outside of that,
when every,
the media was going crazy and even the pup,
the boulder police,
he goes,
they were so far off and he listed like 10 reasons why it wasn't them.
And I kind of felt like an idiot.
I went,
very cool.
I'll buy the book.
I'm going to shut the fuck up.
Now.
The only problem was that that a handwriting expert had connected the mother's
handwriting to the ransom note.
You do get them on this podcast.
We fucking fascinating.
He's doing promotion right now.
I mean I have no idea who killed John [inaudible].
This guy doesn't remember.
I don't think he knows.
No,
no.
He knows.
He can tell you from his 70 years of experience dealing with murders.
It's not the parents,
but he had like evidence why it
wasn't cause I said the same things.
Right.
I'm balls deepened.
Jon Benet,
I grew up around it.
It was like such a cultural phenomenon.
Did he say who he thinks it is?
Yeah,
he did and I forget,
but it's not the panel on who's alive.
I don't know.
You got to have a monitor.
It was so fun.
I'm telling you,
I've listened a shitload of show shit and I was so into this man.
I didn't even promote my special.
I was there a promo,
my special,
I didn't say a word.
I made one stupid calm about Jonbenet's family and then he was like,
shut the fuck up.
Those fucking shows are very compelling.
Then you also see the crime shows.
What do you think?
Why are,
why are we were like,
why am I drawn to him?
I fucked up.
Now.
Why am I drawn to this?
Serial killers are fucked up.
You're just like everybody else because I showed by Charles Manson's pubes on
Ebay.
How much do you pay?
70 Geez man,
I can't even imagine.
72 put his pubes.
They plucked him out so it has some DNA and um,
dude,
you could recreate Charles Manson.
What does this Charles Manson's here,
$2,400 that does this deal bag of hair off the head of Charles Manson was
obtained July,
2016 from an associate of Charles Manson.
Oh No,
that's Leo will be a certificate of authenticity will be included upon purchase.
By the way,
do art.
There are no certificates of authenticity when it comes to Charles Manson's
hair.
It's not like there's an accrediting body who's like,
Hey,
let's definitely,
we'd go over every aspect of this purchase.
That shit's week though,
and you want that 1970s hair straight.
You don't want the updated [inaudible] gray or when he cuts it off.
Really?
Yeah.
You want to film him cutting it off and then you want a vacuum,
seal it and sign it and film the whole thing.
You put it in one of them fucking vacuum bags and bags and then seal it.
Yeah.
That way no one's touched it chops right off his hair.
You've got video footage of it.
You've got video footage of him authorized or a autographing.
The bag,
the fuck is wrong with us.
Why are we talking about this?
It's fascinating to me.
Did you watch the game of Thrones finale?
Did you get bummed out?
I got,
you know what?
Somebody else wrote it.
I think they did.
Yeah.
It's very strange.
I thought they did.
I loved,
I did like season eight and has kids the other seasons.
Hey Lis,
who's felt,
let's get everybody to know right now.
Spoiler alerts.
Hold up.
What is today?
Thursday.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but some people have jobs.
Some people have jobs.
Pregnancy.
Some people work all day,
four days.
Some people were called at the New York Times,
like put it on the front page of the paper up Monday.
Clear Bro.
Serious take your laptop.
But they did that because they can do that and not because they should do that
the next days.
That'll fuck.
Well I think,
I think,
I think movies is,
you got a week movies.
You've got a week,
a TV show.
Two days to,
especially for that.
What are we not supposed to talk about it?
Cause you're busy.
That's insane.
Did you like back what it is?
No,
I didn't [inaudible] satisfied.
I did.
I left unsatisfied when they made a spoiler.
Homeboy the king.
I was like,
what in the fuck are you talking about?
He didn't want it.
The whole,
all the sudden everybody's fighting to the death over who's the king.
They're ready,
ready to stab their brother killed her mom.
They'll kill anybody.
They'll betray lovers.
But now this guy is like a,
all right,
I'll take it.
And everyone's like,
you should be the king.
They're like,
okay,
like that were all great.
And how about that one guy that just stood up and he's like,
maybe I could be the cane.
They're like,
sit down.
Sit It as this.
Just soprano's like what do you,
what are you doing with strange?
This guy,
Bobby Lee had that guy,
Bobby Lee had the greatest,
I thought it's such a good ending.
So he says when everyone goes,
you know,
when the design who to be the king and then homeboy who's crippled is like,
I'll do it.
And then when the wheel on my way,
he just looks over and he has the fucking White Walker I,
oh,
that would work.
And then it closes.
You know what should happen.
It's Bobby Lee's idea.
Jon Snow should've fought to the death with that dude who has no dick.
Yeah.
I want to see that.
The shift to the death,
they hated each other.
They hated each other.
How about that dude was like,
yeah,
you just killed my girl.
CEO.
Big Deal.
Just a you get on the boat.
Yeah.
There's no way they should have fought to the death.
100 did you like episode three?
I'll tell you what I liked though.
They'll like when the one that the hound knocked the mountain off into the fire.
That was dope.
That was,
that was like just that showed me by fire.
They die.
That was a dope scene.
That shit was dope.
The best scene in the whole fucking series though was when under the beds best
scene in the whole fucking series when when she was telling that dude that he
betrayed her and then from the darkness that Dragon's face appears and you're
like,
oh Jesus.
It's where I was a powerful scene.
Those dragons are so fucking so scary.
I'm so happy.
There's people out there that do special effects like that.
That shit was [inaudible] used to be Kinda like Samurai Corny,
like super corny.
You remember what was that movie?
There was a good dragon movie with Matthew mcconaughey back when Matthew
mcconaughey was jacked.
Oh,
fun.
So just brought this up in the show.
Home boy from Australia was in it to Batman.
The fuck's his name.
Oh fuck.
What's his name?
Christian.
Bearish and base.
Your band was in both the fire.
What is it called?
Rain of fire.
Yeah.
The dragons in there were corny compared to the games of Thrones.
Nasbe believe.
Let me see.
Let me see a video that posts look sick.
Obviously we can't show it on the podcast or will get arrested and go cast.
Rachel Carnahan was just talking about this bro.
This fucking movie was not a bad movie.
It was a little corny,
but for a dummy like me who really likes dragons,
it was great stuff.
Um,
it was an interesting movie,
but the dragons,
it's just crazy.
How much,
cause I want to say this was probably 2004.
Am I correct for that 2002 I was pretty close.
Yeah,
pretty close to it you've been on too.
But the difference between what the dragons looked like 17 years later in terms
of flex,
special effects,
even dinosaurs from [inaudible] park.
One to address park world.
Yeah.
Like look at them.
They look,
I'm not showing you much then I that's a dragon's vision though.
It's kind of gay.
Oh,
why is it dragon's vision homosexual?
I wish when I said why did I say that?
Because you're a man.
Why is that?
And we've been doing,
I know why we learn it.
I know.
We've got to reprogram our brains,
dude.
How about with Charlemagne?
I wa I said Bitch,
I went,
oh that bitches hot.
And he goes,
he goes,
in 2019 you're still calling women bitches.
I went,
no where you work.
But yes.
Yeah,
but what apparently says I won't get a good point.
Um,
sometimes I do it on act it like when we were watching fight,
when we do a fight companion,
I attend.
That bitch is tired,
but you don't.
It's all,
here's the thing,
man.
Contents.
Yes.
Don't make more words toxic.
It's all about intent.
Like what are you trying to say?
Like if,
if a,
if a girl is a beast and she's just a bad ass woman and she walks out and she's
got,
I'm good,
I'm good.
And she's got like this crazy tight skirt on his bang and by that she's worked
hard at it in the gym and she's got a beautiful dress and she looks great.
Like,
damn,
that bitch is hot.
That is not negative.
It's not negative.
Is it derogatory though?
But does it?
No,
but it's not negative.
If,
if you go,
you fucking silly bitch to me,
I'll laugh.
I'll fall down on the floor.
I'll start laughing.
Like you can call me a bitch and I think it's funny,
but if you like,
hey man,
you know you fucking made fun of me on the podcast,
Bro.
That was a bitch move.
I'd be like,
Hey,
whoa,
Whoa,
whoa.
But it's different.
Same thing as like when a car drives by,
be like,
damn,
that mother fucker's bad.
But if the guy rolled down his window was a k mother fucker right.
Different,
different,
yeah,
it's intent.
The problem is when you have a word that you can't say,
that word has too much goddamn power.
It's not that you should say the word like don't get me wrong.
Like there's certain words you probably shouldn't say because we've all agreed
that those words have a negative impact probably.
Right?
Yeah.
Faigy we've lost probably one.
We stay away from all greed.
Yeah.
We've all agreed it has a negative impact on people,
but the real problem is intent.
The real problem is homophobic behavior in that,
in that or at home fog,
homophobic thinking,
homophobic ideology,
thought processes,
thinking that gay people are bad thinking there's anything wrong with being gay.
That's a real problem.
If there was no problem with that at all,
I just feel like,
I feel like it's not the right move to make words the problem.
The problem is the way people think and behave and I think ultimately there's a
real problem with language itself because I think language is too limited.
I think we're,
when you have magic words that you can't say and they have all this extra power
connected to it gives them power.
Lenny Bruce talked about that in the 60s he had a great bit about that,
about saying all these words because you could take away the meaning of them and
it won't hurt anybody's feelings anymore.
But don't you think if,
let's say you are a homosexual and gay is like that's what we refer to you as
gay as such a negative connotation because growing up gay men like not good.
So I'd be like,
God,
you look gay dude,
that car's gay.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a problem.
That's problem.
So in great vascular then the problem is it's such a good sound to for that
thought,
the same thing as like calling someone a faggot.
You faggot like that word.
Like when you say it
like that,
even if it's your friend,
like your best friend,
it's got that sag because it sounds good.
It's got a pop to it.
It's going to power.
It starts with a fuck you and starts with an f.
It's so bad.
And it has zero to do with being gay,
but you can't say it anymore because it hurts people's feelings.
Like when Mike Tyson goes,
I'm gonna Fuck you until you love me faggot.
Right,
right,
right.
They make sense.
You're gonna fuck around and call him a faggot.
That was what your fucking hit.
You're trying to fuck him.
Who was the fucking reporter?
He was yelling at us here.
Fuck.
Is that because that guy is,
that guy did he vanished off the face of the earth after that?
I was,
that guy was,
I was ringside when Deontay Walder knocked out Brazil.
I was on Brooklyn for that with my brother,
bro.
Dude,
Bro.
that guy.
It's I and I've been a lot of fun.
I've been in fights.
I've been knocked out.
I've been at UFC fights were dudes get knocked out.
I have never in my life heard someone get knocked out like that.
My brother goes,
oh my God,
and my brothers a brawl dude.
Oh my God.
And they sat us next to his family and it ruined it for me because you can't
cheer.
I saw the wife Elijah.
I just went,
oh my God,
I didn't chew.
I wouldn't cheer anyway,
but I was just like,
oh my God.
And this is the funniest part is uh,
my boy shout out to Brian.
Brian Dailey at showtime goes,
so in between rounds,
um,
probably uh,
two and three.
Jim Gray's going to come in and interview about your,
a showtime special on you.
Oh,
that,
that'd be cool if they told me the day before.
So yet this nice outfit.
My brother's looking on the,
I really think it was going to get to run toward go under four.
I didn't think one round,
but I thought there was a chance they sent me there and that they're like Jim
Guy,
he's going to come and then [inaudible].
All right.
I should probably get out of here.
Huh?
John to dude,
I'm telling you man,
he's something special.
So special man.
He's such a good dude.
You've never had them on here was amazing.
He's great.
We had a great time.
How passionate is he?
He's a sweetheart.
He's like a really nice guy.
That was my problem with him going,
Oh,
I want to murder this guy.
I want to kill this guy and I want to exercise my right.
I'm like,
ah,
I expect that from these,
for lack of better term,
these animals,
these guys who aren't at your level,
but he's such a good person.
I'm like,
ah,
dude,
don't do that.
Cause they can paint you into that box.
I believe that's going to just go away,
but it's gone.
That's gone.
It's gone.
His performance was so spectacular.
I think it goes away,
but I think it's also that was his legitimate mindset at that time.
You know what I mean?
That guy,
if you listen to my podcast when I interviewed him and talked about how he got
into boxing because of his daughter,
just do it on yours as well.
Talk about that.
Yeah.
That's a special person,
man.
I mean he became a bronze medalist in the Olympics after a year and a half of
boxing.
That's insane.
So specialties,
that's insane,
man.
You got to imagine he was Bob.
If he was in a year and a half of boxing and he's entering into Olympics,
he's going to be having matches against guys who have 10 years experience,
easy,
hundreds of fights,
100 amateur fights,
hundreds and he's got like virtually no experience.
And
he's not like the slickest guy in the world either.
So he has to be able to take a shot.
But he's got two giant advantages,
huge reach and ridiculous power.
And I think lettuces because,
yeah,
and I think because of the fact that he's not a big heavyweight,
I don't think he gets his tired as they do.
I agree.
I think he came in this last fight,
the heavy seas ever been.
He came in at two 23 and what did he really,
that's interesting cause usually two 14 to 13 to solve,
get this mother fucker.
He punches so hard,
man.
He's the scariest heavyweight knockout artist since Mike Tyson.
Hundred percent when he was walking.
Well you Gregory,
when he's walking,
I looked up my brother,
I went,
I went.
You know how you feel right now?
You had goosebumps.
I want imagine being on Mike Tyson,
fight in,
in his prime.
How that fucking crowd must've felt.
Yeah,
because when he's walking out,
I felt so bad for Brazil because I'm like,
we're next to his family.
I'm like,
he's such an underdog.
He's going to get knocked out.
[inaudible] I think we're going to see that with Deontay wilder.
I think Deontay wilder.
It's a pneumonic.
Tyson hundred percent I think he's the new Mike.
He's that hard and what's instrumented him is everyone gives me shit like you're
such a homer cause you work for showtime.
No,
no,
no.
Here's the thing about that,
Joe.
What people don't realize is Deontae while his fights are on showtime,
he's an independent contractor.
He doesn't have a promoter.
He says,
team,
you know the design often hundreds of billions of dollars,
same as they offer Joshua and canal.
He turned it down.
Dan.
You know why?
Because he wants,
he wants to fight Joshua's to fight fear.
He goes,
well,
if I'm with them,
that's going to limit me fighting fury or Joshua.
If I'm independent,
I can fight.
Joshua can fight wilder.
If I was up Joshua or wild,
I'd be terrified.
Right now.
Why do you think they me not wild or rather a fury.
Joshua fewer.
I'd be terrified of that mind,
that mindset.
Definitely easier fights.
But he's the scariest fight of all time in the fucking 12th round when he cracks
Tyson fury and drops in like that.
You're like in the 12th round,
he still has this ridiculous power and he's only getting better.
But I think what happens is him,
it's more likely,
especially looking at the way promoters work.
You didn't get Joshua verse wilder before he get fury.
Oh,
I think so.
I think it was just kind of,
so all I'm taking any of them.
Yeah,
I'm fine.
I want all three of them.
I do these fucks.
Oh,
it these flux.
It's context.
Remember these fucks oh it to yes to the legacy of box in a fight each other.
Well,
it's one of those rare moments in the heavyweight division where you have three
unbelievably compelling guys.
And then one of them was a former champion who by the way,
the last fight was a draw and I thought he should have wanted decision.
So if you look at it,
I thought he should have wanted decision,
but I agree with the results too.
This is what's real squirrely preach.
Because the way Wildred heard him,
dropped him and then knocked him down and almost had him flat lined in the 12th
end.
If you go over the actual count,
the actual 10 count from one to 10 from the time he dropped,
which is not what Tyson's series jobs is,
Tyson fury jobs get up in.
The referee says nine and he did that.
He did that.
But if you go buy an actual clock,
11 or 12 and yeah,
you go buy an actual clock.
It's about 11 and 12 second yeah.
Tyson fury lost that 10 count.
But fear,
purity one the rounds.
Yes.
Siri.
One more rounds.
Hands down the outbox him.
Did you write that count was longer than 10 yeah,
he,
he should have.
If you were just going by 10 seconds.
Deontay wilder has a real argument that should,
he should have won by knockout.
Here's the thing,
that's why I liked the draw the draw.
Fantastic.
Cool.
Run it back.
Let's get a clear winner.
And then Joshua,
who's this animal out there?
Who's just this fucking,
he's so damn good.
He's just honestly though,
what the fuck is a 10 count?
Four if it's not 10 seconds.
Why is the referee human error accounts human error.
There should be in every fucking corner,
every corner,
wherever the fight is.
There should be a clock.
And then once someone goes down,
someone else,
not the referee hits that button.
[inaudible] second one.
Oh you could really do three,
four,
five,
six cause cause you go one,
two,
three,
four,
five.
Yeah.
But he goes one that he's jacked up with adrenaline.
There's a huge knock out the crowd.
Like want a guy to get up.
He might want to,
got to get up.
He might want to help them extra time to rub the gloves on his chest.
Ask him a couple of questions and they grabbed that towards me.
Walk towards me.
What's Today's date?
You could do all that shit.
You can give them a little bit of a break.
Do you like to Hu human error part like same with baseball.
Like the jumps.
They fuck up.
No.
All the time to the greatest of the greats like Herb Dean and John McCarthy.
Have you made mistakes?
You,
it is impossible to not fuck up.
Herb Dean is the Goddamn gold standard.
He's the best of the best of people working today.
And he will occasionally say that he made an error.
John Daughter.
Yeah.
Amazing.
Amazing,
fun mixing people make mistakes.
They're human beings and I think is there John though,
bro?
Their job is so I fuck up all the time and I do commentary and their job is so
much harder than mine.
So much harder.
All I'm doing is talking while the fights going on,
what they're deciding.
If the fight ends,
I disagree.
Voice to go fucking mad.
This is bro.
It's not that Oh yard to watch another organization go watch another or when
you're not working.
Since I'm not being,
I'm not,
I'm not being humble.
I'm just telling you it's not that hard.
You,
brother,
I'm telling you,
it's a tough fucking gig.
Go watch another fight.
Go,
go watch.
Go Watch design.
We Canelo fought.
It was so bad.
It was comical.
Who was doing the commentary?
Not sure.
Does it matter?
Not Good.
It was so bad.
It ruined the fight.
That kind of,
it was so bad.
It was entertaining.
Well,
they were show pro Canelo and they just weren't,
it wasn't professionally done.
You know who I like that uh,
is in a world of shit right now.
You get a,
you're talking to MMA or boxing.
Who?
Paulie.
Malignaggi.
Uh,
what's the best,
why is he spitting on people?
What's he doing?
Macy,
great commentator,
man.
I threw me the best.
He's the best.
I think my number one favorite.
Here's,
here's my three top that I get excited when they're doing the same as mine.
Roy Jones Jr Andre Ward and Paulie Malignaggi.
I think you could see Andre and Polly both.
You can switch out [inaudible] like Roy because Roy Christ in me.
Yeah,
that's okay though.
This is why when he was at his best,
he was the motherfucker of all motherfuckers.
He was like,
Floyd Mayweather,
but he was knocking people dead.
He was putting his hands behind his back and knocked people out.
He was doing shit that no one could do.
He was fucking people up.
Roy Jones Jr went on a streak for a long time where he was,
he had this freak athleticism in this.
He didn't even throw jabs half the time.
Three.
Love your,
appreciate it.
Oh my God.
So you,
because the end of his career at them,
well,
you know when Glen Johnson Kao Dim when um,
uh,
magic man k owed him,
but that was,
but he had this run of greatness that we should appreciate.
Like,
like when I think of Anderson Silva,
I don't think of him bitch out because he got kicked against Khan there.
I think of Anderson Silva fucking front kick and Vito Belfort Front kick and
fucking,
you know,
all these guys.
Like of course I think of that.
So it's weird with Roy,
I think because he's currently,
he just got knocked down in Russia like six days ago or whatever.
Did he really know?
But you recently got knocked in Russia,
but I thought he won his last fight.
I think he won his last fight.
That's going to be his last last wildfly Seattle.
Yeah.
Paulie's amazing though.
But Paulie,
um,
when he,
when he was going to fight,
um,
that bare knuckle,
I want a little bit of rant on my show.
Me and polio close,
man.
I went on a rant and I was saying,
I don't think you should do it.
And it,
I feel like he's punching down.
He's one of the best commentators.
Here's a job.
So many people want then of course me and probably work together.
So we're breaking down the wilder Brazil fight in New York and there was this
weird Pollyanna gonna hear this there.
I felt like there's this weird kind of,
well,
of course.
I mean,
you're telling them not to do something that he's definitely going to do.
Yeah,
I know.
So you're resisting his idea.
But if I was doing something you didn't want me to do,
if you're doing something right and we have an open conversation with,
there's no weirdness.
Like,
why can't we talk about if Polly went up to him was like,
dude,
I'm doing it cause I'm like this fuck out.
Do and hopefully I get McGregor out.
And also I'm just kind of bored with my life.
Man,
this could be fun for me.
I went,
oh cool man,
I support you.
There's no,
I'm not shaming him.
I agree with you.
I feel where you're coming from.
And I agree that I would want you to tell me if you thought it was fucking up
and it was a bad idea.
But I think that,
um,
with a guy like him,
you know,
this is,
he not,
I don't know what kind of options he has.
Nobody was beating down his door to fight him,
you know,
and that,
I know that Connor didn't want to fight him.
He wasn't interested in that.
And I don't know other,
what other options he's got [inaudible] for boxing,
but then also,
so,
but then that's what I'm saying,
the greatest analysts in the game,
but he,
if he's going to fight a bare knuckle boxing fight like this,
got it.
There's gotta be a financial motive for that.
That's,
I would hope that the only thing that makes sense is that that's a financial
motive.
But I listened to showtime paste them.
Showtime pays them well do they?
Yeah,
man.
Yeah.
So it's like to do that,
you know,
and you look at the payday,
like automate I think 50,000 for the last fight.
So let's,
so let's say they pay him triple,
let's pain,
quadruple say make,
what does that fucking $250,000 is that enough to do a bare knuckle fight when
you're making six figures,
you know you could get your face fucked up too.
That's the reality.
Those knuckles,
man,
I'm,
I'm changing my tune a little bit,
but not all them on.
You got a little bit in Gel a little bit,
but here's the thing,
like you do get caught up more in bare knuckle boxing,
but you're also not kicking or using take downs or anything else in bare knuckle
boxing.
I think it'd be way more brutal if there was take down and kicks because with
maybe,
I don't think the best guy wins.
Also in a bare knuckle cause you know Polly has way more fighting experience in
art.
Right?
Susie?
Again,
more scar tissue.
So if there's a guy with a ton of scar tissue,
your face opens up like a,
it looks like a murder scene taking Charles Manson murder scene because of the
knuckles.
So he might,
you might land seven shots to his too,
but your face is fucked up.
They,
us nothing cuts you up more than elbows and elbows are a hundred percent legal
in the UFC and the the [inaudible] unless his ground and pound.
Mm.
Yeah,
like standard.
Like I can't like all that you can while he does that.
How about Johnnie Walker?
Johnnie Walker's gotten nasty.
He gonna get fucked.
It's,
he really hurt cause you haven't heard from at all.
Right?
I think he recovered like whatever was wrong with his shoulder recovered.
But the reality is if you're,
if you hurt yourself so bad that you can't move your arm afterwards.
Coming from someone who's had some shoulder injuries,
that to me is like you've got some damage in there.
You know why else?
It's alarming because when he did it,
his adrenaline was so high.
Usually you can go through some shit if you got hurt bad enough where your
adrenaline's you.
I mean you're,
you just want a huge fight.
You're doing the worm after victory and you can feel the pain.
That's when I'll fuck there's,
there's probably damaged there.
Yeah,
cause you're drilling so high.
It numbs every,
just imagine if that one's up defining his career.
I don't think developed shoulder problems.
I hope not already.
Clover clover's had some serious shoulder palms ever since the John Fife.
It's also 70 years old.
He's been fighting in Brazil since he was three,
but when John grabbed his arm and yanked it back when Glover was the top
contender member,
John got him in that over Hook and ripped his fucking arm up my bro.
That was,
I never saw anybody do that before.
I was like,
that's genius.
That's a really smart thing because you're fucking super vulnerable in that
position.
Nobody really thinks that Americans just grabs and goes.
Yup.
Just yanked it shoulder.
John's the goat.
The goat.
He used to go close.
Well he is him and the best expression in terms of like what I've seen in the
octagon is mighty mouse.
But he had just didn't fight different level of competition except for so Hutto
we're finding out.
So who knows the fucking man.
Here's the thing,
we're definitely finding that out.
So then my dumb ass,
he's going,
he knows I love fucking my mess.
I humor John can do one or two.
The problem with him be a number one is that that weight class,
the,
the margin of error is way higher.
So if I go,
if I zig left when I showed zig,
right,
I'm not getting knocked down.
I can learn from go back.
If John Zigs left when she went right by Glover,
he's getting knocked the fuck out.
Get margins are so small.
John can take a shot.
But if it's rumble Johnson,
he's getting knocked out.
Maybe.
Yeah,
we don't know John's that good.
But the thing is,
let's see here was the mighty mouse.
So when he beat pseudo rights,
who had seven fights the first time smoked them.
So who took gains experience?
Then he beats him.
Yup.
So that takes the pound for pound.
That takes a little off of mighty mouse.
But I think he's,
as you agree with the decision,
when pseudo beat him,
it's so tough to talent.
It's tough.
It's fucking,
listen,
if they would've gave to mighty mouse,
I would've been mad at,
I wouldn't have been mad at you.
And how about your boys?
Sage Northcutt yeah.
Cosmo Alexander.
Cosmo killed a guy.
He's a beast to sage is still in the hospital.
17 fractures in his face.
Yeah,
I know.
He's still not won championships and killed the guy outside of that.
No,
because you know,
surgery Crow Cova love did.
Yeah,
I know.
Coppola have killed a guy in a fight.
Um,
well,
cosmo logs.
Andrew is a worldclass more Thai fighter.
I mean,
John Wayne par fought him,
you know,
he fought.
Nikki holds can,
he's world class as far as striking.
It's a completely different level.
But I guess because it was an MMA fight,
he was willing to take it,
but they,
they fought,
stand up for management and sage took that karate stance and the dude circled
off,
um,
to his right in Atlanta,
that fucking right hand and it was on the business.
The hardest right hand I've ever seen.
I was,
can you imagine?
I can't think just from a world class striker with flounce gloves on and he's
circling into the right.
Yeah.
And it's like a fucking bomb.
It's pretty God damn strong.
And Cosmos is a beast of a man.
I mean,
he's a big thick dude.
See,
I mean,
a big thick dude with multiple world titles to his name.
Don't you feel bad watch?
How do you feel bad for sage?
Yeah,
it's a terrible match up.
I don't know why they,
uh,
agreed to let him fight that guy.
Boom.
It's just not smart because that,
because the,
the kickboxing in the standup,
like he doesn't have the experience.
I don't know.
He's,
I mean,
sage is good.
He's very good.
But these,
these kinds of losses are terrible for a few,
for his future because their mismanagement losses in my opinion.
I agree.
I think sage is what 20 to like look at that punch that lands.
I mean that is ferocious from a worldclass try.
Yeah.
I mean that's sort of left full blast to that is a full blast.
She sugar right?
You can't,
you can't get hit cleaner than that.
Now you came here.
It's be hard to hit a fucking,
but meanwhile,
do you ever seen him when he fought Nikki hold skin?
Uh,
cosmos.
Yeah.
You gotta keep class.
Michelle's can fuck him up.
There is the three levels.
There's levels but in MMA sages and even remote,
he shouldn't be,
they shouldn't be shinned same marine.
Well Cosmo's,
why would I,
why would I bring this,
this stud,
this American Stud who looks like right from street fighter and go,
Hey,
first fight,
here's the most worldclass director we got on the roster.
Well,
because they want him to be tested.
And I think that if I was a cha tree,
I would be looking at it like this.
When a guy like Eddie Alvarez gets code or a guy like sage Northcutt kits code
or a guy mighty mouse gets tagged and has a real fight on his hands,
then you're showing the whole world like,
Hey,
these guys that are coming over here that are world class fighters,
they're fighting worldclass fighters.
I did it get knocked out.
I get that here on the other.
It's a great thing for him.
I think certain certain.
So with uh,
Eddie Alvarez of veteran,
he should be hall of Famer Bell Champ,
UFC champ.
Give him the best she got.
He's seen it all to be tough to get bone passed them.
Sage Northcutt mighty mouse.
Give him the best you got.
He's seen it all.
Good luck getting past him.
Sage.
Northcutt you're investing in his future.
He's not ready.
It's good point.
You've kind of fucked a man.
Well,
so you're trying to get in the American market,
but Cosmo's not an MMA fighter.
That's the thing.
This is cosmos first.
MMA fight would sage just takes them down and smashes him.
That would've been great.
Yeah.
But I mean that could have happened too.
So when you,
when concerts last say style,
he's not a grappler.
Okay.
But he knows how to grapple.
Say just taking guys down in the octagon before taking cosmo downs easier than
said he's trained with me and Rashad at Black Zealand's them.
Fuck us up today.
Yeah.
The nightmare.
So when I saw it for sage,
I'm like,
what also are you building cosmo?
He's older man.
While he's only 34 37 is e three seven has 1000 kickboxing matches.
Like you're gonna invest in that now from a business aspect.
Doesn't make sense to me.
I think it does though because it shows with two giant results over the last two
months.
That one has world class talent there and I think it makes people pay more
attention to one,
not me.
It put me off of him.
Really?
Yeah.
Oh that's crazy.
Fucked up.
No,
see,
listen man,
I'm a sideshow is a fucking Moy Thai fighter.
I mean that's his bread and butter.
He fights Moyie Thai since his bread and butter.
So when cosmo goes and fights in an MMA fight,
you would think at least in one area,
is going to be at a disadvantage.
If stay sage chooses to have a stand up fight with a worldclass Dan fighter,
that's just bad strategy.
It's that state sages game,
those,
especially as a young fighter,
but he's a mixed martial arts fighter,
then he should become a kickboxer if that's his game is just to stand up and
strike the people that just stay a kickboxer.
Because if you're going to find,
listen man,
if you're gonna fight in MMA,
in MMA,
you could do everything.
What do you want to do in this fight?
Don't you want to win?
Okay,
good.
I want you to win.
Here's how you win.
You don't stand with one of the best fucking strikers in the world.
How old is he?
22 sage.
Come on.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but you just tell him I says Twitter sizes strategy.
You,
you keep that side stance.
That's fine Beta man.
But then shoot,
get,
just get the clench and drag that mother fucker to the ground.
Let's where I'm out.
I'm with Ya.
Which he's never done to any fight ever put,
let's ask taken guys down before.
Yeah,
but let's say you serious manager and they go,
Hey,
here's cosmetic.
Go.
Hold on.
Let's just let me go through this.
With these sage prose,
you beat a straight worldclass,
kickboxer and MMA.
He's also 37 years old.
Not a lot of pros.
Cons,
okay,
but he's 37 years.
He came down.
He fucking starches you in your face is broken 17 places and your career is
probably not going well.
The trajectory is definitely off the rails.
Pros,
cons,
that's true.
It's just,
if you look at the way boxing has always done it and it's been often criticized,
but there's some real good points to it about developing a fighter.
You give a guy a fighter,
a difficult fight that you think that he has the advantage in,
but it's an advantage that will teach him some things like the f.
Then the guy fights with them.
What does this Jimmy Cosmo's ninth fight was against stage.
Oh,
he's had a bunch of MMA fights.
Why did he say that?
He knocks out everybody.
He set it on his,
um,
his,
uh,
what the fuck is Instagram post about us?
Know that he doesn't fight MMA.
No fuck on gender.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Start to everyone will championship goes here you go.
Yeah.
He looked at yours I guess.
Oh,
I was 16.
Three years for you though.
May cause he's training with the best of the best as well.
Bottom line is as a striker,
he's superb and he's,
he's fucking,
but then as hard crazy,
the thing is pull up the Nicky holds can fight.
Nikki holds,
can knocks out cosmo.
Alexandra,
that just shows you how many levels there are.
But then Nikki whole skin just lost to a region.
Ursel just lost to him.
Just got dropped with a knee.
It's so interesting man.
When you see levels upon levels upon levels and you don't necessarily know that
these levels even exist unless you're balls deep in the fucking sport.
Like you see a guy like Niki for Princeville and Nikki's like,
wow,
the best body punchers in kickboxing and this is a kickboxing fight as opposed
to a Moyie Thai fight as well.
So no elbows limited.
Clenching and,
uh,
you can only hold for like three seconds when you and throw a knee.
You can only like,
you can only hold while you're like think one knee at a time or something like
that.
They have weird rules.
You know.
Here's the thing,
the fact that cosmo Alexander went toe to toe with Nikki Holton,
I'm probably going to pass on my young 22 year old wide eyed youngster fighting
him.
Nikki holes can had an amazing career in glory to some fucking incredible
siphon.
Joseph [inaudible] where he knocked him out in the last round.
Yeah,
he's a,
he's a beast man.
Super,
super tactical and it's just tough as shit.
Yeah.
I mean,
look,
it's just the way these guys are standing in front of it that just checking
everything.
Perfect.
Perfect technique.
Perfect defense.
Oh,
we dropped him with that left hook.
Yeah.
Look,
hold skins.
I'm a monster.
This is by the way,
a kickboxing fight.
Holtz can also fought Kosmal og Sandra and knocked him out in one FC.
This is,
uh,
this is,
it's showtime in Amsterdam.
This is quite a few years ago.
It's showtime was the shit man.
He should get it on access TV back when access TV was HD net over that Mark
Cuban's fog 14.
That was dealt with at the MMA live with Ron Crook.
Yes.
I used to go on there all the time.
Bas Rutan and who's the other guy that boss ruin was on with our boy.
Maranello no,
no,
no.
The other guy,
there was another guy who was on Kenny.
Kenny.
Ready say rice.
Yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
What's it Myra on there too,
for a long time?
I don't
know.
Was moral on that.
Myra was on their mind crate.
Am I going crazy?
Kenny was on there though.
Katie.
It was definitely on there,
but my truck was the best.
They used to have all these great kickboxing matches from like Amsterdam and
shit.
But you see ESPN now has a Pfl on it if you want to do that,
if you're a palsy day of Pfl was on that.
Yeah.
I would see the lunch at times.
The,
um,
I've been on a couple of times,
but the um,
what the first nine seasons in associate by Kenny Rice.
Oh,
and then moral came on later.
Yeah.
Can he use to fly in from uh,
Kentucky?
I remember just fly and do the show.
Fly back out.
I'm like,
for sure.
Huh?
Yeah.
Well maybe really likes Kentucky and he loved it half to what do you like about
it?
I have,
I don't know.
Kentucky Derby once a year.
Keep you there.
Is that what it is?
Bourbon.
I want to go to the Kentucky Derby to let stress chronic acid.
I'm so down for that.
And where did they wear suits?
Like dumb and dumber.
Yeah.
Next get sloshed off fucking bourbon.
Got next year I take acid and go to the derby.
That buffalo trace a distillery or whatever that
buffalo trace distillery.
Did I drink whiskey?
Ah,
almost every day now.
Really know what's happening there.
I don't know.
I'm getting older.
I got the palate for whiskey.
A lot of stress.
What about cigars?
Do like scars?
Nope,
not my thing yet.
I like olives.
I used to hate all this.
Love Olives now and whiskey,
dude.
I don't know why.
That's hilarious.
What whiskey is this?
I'm a little more,
by the way.
Um,
what's it called again?
Jamie Blanton's.
Blanton's.
It is delicious.
I have no idea.
It could have been Sam angels.
Anybody could have brought,
I don't remember.
Honestly.
This can't be cheap.
Just feeling this goblet,
this grenade goblet.
They got into this game of Thrones.
Goblet is sick.
Someone gave me Johnny Walker,
White Walker.
Whiskey.
Shout at night.
Feldman White Walker whiskey,
bringing that shit up.
Jane White Walker.
Whiskey limited damage.
Drones.
In addition.
I'm not drinking that Zombie pissed
go bottles.
So sick.
I don't want people touching it.
Really?
Oh,
it's a collector's item in collecting.
We collected bottles of game of Thrones.
Oh my God.
That shit,
Bro.
Is it sold out?
Enzo Ferrari.
Oh,
they want that for you to have your birthday,
John.
Yeah.
Dude.
How dope is.
That's pretty cool.
Here's a white walker.
Yeah,
but what do you want to be aligned with the biggest fucking assholes in the
realm?
Come on,
Johnny Walker.
I wish they would've Johnnie Walker with the Nazis.
I will say with Johnny Walker Nazi Vodka.
What'd you,
what'd you buy that?
No.
Why the fuck you bind White Walker whiskey that's or white Walker Bourbon or
whatever it is.
There's a Gif,
bro.
Fuck that.
They can eat the white wall.
Can you drive my fry home bro for me?
I'll give you get hammered bad
when it minds stick around.
Yeah.
Shoot some arrows.
Shoots is getting the flow tank.
Relax my friends relax.
So while there are some other good fights that happened this weekend,
oh dude,
hop held those.
Sandra's versus Kevin Lee.
Um,
I didn't see a bro.
That's how busy I've been.
I was at the wilder fight.
I missed the,
I know.
It doesn't just look good and be Kevin Lee.
Kevin and needs a new camp.
Heavenly needs a camp.
Yeah.
I think Kevin Lee should go to for us a hobby.
That's my advice or Jackson.
Well,
the reason why for outside Bobby is cause Kevin Lee skill set is very similar to
George.
Saint Pierre is quite striking,
poetic,
very athletic and great timing of his takedowns.
Nobody knows how to coach that better than frost a,
it's a good idea.
Yeah.
It's not bad at all.
So what I think who'd old,
uh,
Aaron Peko just went to Jackson's?
Yes.
I think that's a great move to Pico.
Oh yeah.
I hooked him up with my boy Vinny shoreman too.
So,
uh,
I,
I told him that I think that he should go to frost.
So hobbies and I told them about Vinny shoreman,
who's a incredible mental coach.
You know,
he's got to be champ.
She believe that if he gets his shit together and goes to a legit camp because
you remember it's coach passed away,
right?
Yeah.
Folders.
Who was very close with them to Shane.
Amazing,
amazing guy.
And so he passed away and then it was like,
he was like,
oh,
I'll just stay here and put together this kind of rag tag group and we'll figure
it out at the UFC now is at such a high level to compete with the guys he's
competing with.
You got to have a good camp man.
Like a legit,
yeah.
Coach,
head coach,
leader.
It's no disrespect to any small camps or small gyms.
Don't have the experience.
No,
I'm not.
I'm not trying to be,
I'm just saying that an athlete has a small fucking window man.
Like Kevin is a 26.
Right?
So he's got 10 years.
The last one,
it's three out of his last four.
Yeah.
Not Good.
UFC don't play with that.
Chan before that,
I was a PFL leading guys in pretty spectacular fashion.
Right.
Robert Foal was his death had a tremendous impact on him as a fighter,
as a person.
And then he fought some really great fighters too on top of that,
you know,
and uh,
ally,
Quintin man,
I mean from the jump of that fight from the,
the get go,
when he hit him with that spinning back fist,
he let them know like,
this is,
you're in a dog fight,
man.
Tony Ferguson fight was a dog fight.
A dog fight.
Yeah.
These guys have dogfights and uh,
when the tour would be first and fight,
he had a staph infection clear 100%.
And he looked good though.
20 hold me down was going down.
Choked out.
God is my fucking God,
man.
Look when you have,
you've had staff before,
right?
Yeah.
It's awful.
And the way it drains your body,
it drains your body.
Well the staff does too.
I mean if you get it too is as far as where it is with him.
He's in a full infection.
He has a full infection so it's in his blood stream.
But the thing that fucks your cardio and your energy like like no other,
they antibiotics.
Fuck you.
So bad to do.
But so does the staff,
especially when it's that bad.
I mean he's got a fucking giant squirrel growing out of his tit.
Remember that?
What could you told DC not saying.
That's how I saw it.
Immediately he walked into the octagon.
I'm like,
he's got staff.
Got that staff out decent.
Say I go,
hey did DC I go,
is that staff that looks like staff to me and they go do not talk about the
staff.
He goes,
that looks like staff to meet Joe.
These,
he doesn't give her like,
bitch,
you talking to Daniel Cormier there when you're talking about the guy who knows
stuff better than anyone.
That Guy Dan Marino,
fuck out of here.
It's like a wrestling coach.
Listen,
we would be doing a massive disservice to the viewing public if we did admit
that it was staff.
It's a far,
it's part of the drama.
It's part of what makes the fights interesting.
But my take on Kevin Lee is,
he's a great guy.
I really,
I'm going to have him on again.
He's going to come on again.
So he's the best.
He's a great person.
I like talking to him tomorrow because I'll put them on the food truck.
Diarrhea.
Okay.
He's great.
I'll text you.
I'll split the cost with you woody row.
Nah,
don't worry about it.
Um,
but anyway,
um,
I,
there's a,
there's a defining moment in a fighter's career when they realize they need to
make changes.
They're not doing things the way they should be doing them and they need to make
some changes.
But I think one of the reasons why you care,
and I care,
especially with Kevin,
if it was somebody else,
some other guys,
I won't mention names,
but with Kevin I go,
well no,
he can be champ.
He just has to change a few things here.
You see this kid is champion in another kind of like catch,
keep doing what you're doing.
He hunted or 100% is the skills and the mindset and he has the full package.
He looks good,
speaks good dress as well,
has the skills sign me up.
He's a good person to talk to.
So when you talk to him was a good feel.
It really is a good person.
He's just got to make some changes and he needs a maestro.
He needs a fucking conductor.
He needs a Greg Jackson.
Matt Hume can't get there without it.
These Duke Roufus uh,
Mike Brown at att.
Yup.
Do that.
Does employee on food diaries and that's amazing.
I'm sorry,
not my brand I does employee on,
but he's talking about Mike Brown.
How great is that dust in the diamond Poria and um,
he started talking about his wife,
dude.
I,
I'm balls deep into chicken waffles,
eating the food truck,
you know,
stuff.
And he starts talking about her and we're probably 30 minutes in it.
I started getting teary eyed.
He starts container,
right?
Oh,
he's just talking about how,
um,
cause I was telling him like,
dude,
it's a long journey.
However you're not like,
I can't believe you didn't stop at some point like you've been doing since
you're 18.
I haven't gotten stopped.
And he goes,
I wouldn't,
he was onsite.
He goes,
I haven't said this before.
I would've stopped.
Like I,
I've thought about retiring and my wife told me I can't.
She's like,
give me these pep talks.
And like that's nuts,
man.
How long have you been willing?
It goes,
oh,
she drove me to my first fight,
my first fight before I got out of the car.
I get emotional now because before I get out of the car,
she told me going to be world champion.
Whoa,
dude.
I got shit.
I'm like,
Dude,
you get me fucking chills.
I'm like,
well,
not because you are a champ,
people would always interim champ.
I don't care.
It's still part of chain.
One of the best fighters on earth.
Pound for pound.
Yeah.
I'm 45 great.
Top three be the best 145 pounder ever.
And he's without a doubt one of the best pound for pound fighters in the world.
Dustin beat him.
Yup.
Yeah.
There's no doubt about it.
So he said he's a champion,
some form.
He still,
he has a belt and then you made it.
And I told him,
I said,
uh,
I'm terrible at this.
So this is me telling you this by me deflect and what I should be doing.
But you know you're going to fight cubby.
And I said,
I don't a fuck how that fight goes.
You've done it brother.
When you were 18 you decided to go on this journey,
become UFC champion.
You had all these dreams,
your wife,
how many sacrifices?
You guys have a little girl now and you're there,
man.
I said,
I don't care if could be beat your ass for five rounds.
You've done it,
dude.
How cray.
I was pleased to hear that though.
Nobody wants to hear.
I don't care if could be,
but what I'm telling him is you've,
you've succeeded.
Mission accomplished,
mother mission,
a comp.
I went,
how crazy is that?
Their mission accomplished.
What did he think though?
Probably doesn't think like that.
I probably thinks he's still on the quest.
I don't think you can.
Do you think like that?
Do I think that the guys who have that weird engine in adult think like that?
I've never,
like I've,
I've never felt more not to make it about,
I've never felt more pressured my life to come up with new,
become a better comic than when I released my special,
of course I'm like,
Oh shit,
now,
now the work starts.
That was whatever to how to work stone ever satisfied with myself.
More than like 1520 minutes a week.
Mostly.
I wish I had 15 minutes where I was.
I couldn't tell you it was,
I've seen 20 minutes a week I'll have a glass of wine.
I'll put my feet up,
I'll kick back and then the little voice in the back of my head,
it's like,
are you doing everything you can do?
Get up.
C'Mon.
It's kind of a shit ton of a demon.
Those as Joe,
like 100% like my,
one of my dreams was to buy the car that I bought and I bought it and we're in
bed.
Micro goes,
how do you feel it
exactly the same like I think what you like,
material things,
they don't matter at all and then next day we wake up my my,
I get it when my son every morning and we always watched cars on youtube and she
goes,
what the f?
I'm watching a different car.
She goes,
what the fuck you doing?
I'm like looking at the next car.
She's like,
there's no way.
I'm like,
I need,
I need goals.
As soon as we bought a,
bought our house,
I swear to God the next morning she was,
what are you doing truly ago looking at the next house?
I don't know what to do now though.
That's normal.
I message to Dustin was enjoying this but don't get the thing about stuff though
as opposed to like goals is like stuff you could always just keep buying stuff
and making money to buy stuff and then you find yourself being one of those
people that just does stuff for money because you want to buy this stuff.
I've never done that.
But there are people like that out there.
Right.
You know,
I've heard Steve Harvey talk about money,
like how much money he wants to make per year and,
and someone was making fun of it and I was thinking,
well,
he's in this vibe where he's trying to get stuff and make money and you've got
to make money to get stuff and you get sort of in this game of accumulating more
and bigger and better things.
For me,
the most important thing is the stuff that I put out.
If people like it,
like if I do a podcast,
let's say if I do a UFC and I suck,
if I stumble through something or I make a bad call or it's not,
that shit will fuck be up for days.
And there's nothing you can do to nothing I could do to fix it.
You had to get a the Lamborghini on Friday.
It's like there's enough fill.
That void wouldn't do a damn thing.
So same with a podcast.
If I do a podcast that doesn't go well,
if I do a set,
the set doesn't go well or stumble through a joke.
All I care about is the stuff that I do in terms of like agree,
like progress.
I focus all my progress in that.
I'll distract myself with stuff,
but like look,
this watch costs like 50 bucks or something.
I don't know.
Yeah,
I've been taught earlier that's a taser,
not 50 but military watch looks like 300 bucks maybe.
You know what I'm saying?
But it doesn't matter whether that's 500 or 300 bucks or this is 22 grand.
Not a big deal.
22 grand,
25 grand.
It doesn't Matte American money.
Gas,
stone,
cold cash.
Not a big deal.
Rolex talking,
just talking shit.
You're just talking shit.
Just talking shit,
but no Rolex.
My point is,
is this like that doesn't make you happy.
Does it make you feel anyway?
This doesn't make me feel any way.
None of it.
The more I learned,
the more I accumulate these material things.
It does.
It mean she doesn't help.
The only thing that means shit is your friends and your loved ones and what
you're trying to do with your life.
Bob Dylan said it best.
He said he,
they said,
uh,
you know,
what's,
what's success to you?
He goes,
not having to work for assholes and waking up,
going to bed,
doing exactly what I want.
Yeah.
Boom.
Set.
Match.
You already doing.
I'm already doing that.
The only time I ever felt,
I guess somewhat successful,
I'd really don't,
but the only time I felt a little successful is when I turned down a big Gig on
a major network to do TV.
I went,
now I'm kind of good man.
I'm good doing what I want to do and I own all this stuff and I don't,
I don't,
I'm not pressed to do it.
Do you imagine what it'd be like if you had a boss?
Remember the shit that you guys were dealing with at Fox?
We were telling you to stop cursing on the fighter and the kid.
Hilarious to imagine how bad that advice is.
Think about how many fucking millions of downloads of the fighter and the kid
had been out there.
How many humans on the planet earth have you could see an overhead map of all
the people on the planet.
A light went off every time a dude was listening to the fighter and the kid,
he's like,
holy fuck.
It would freak you out and see that number and that Fox guy was like cleaning up
wise.
You know what that guy told me to?
I started arguing with him.
He kind of got my face and went just like you have your black belt in the
octagon.
I got my black belt and TV.
Oh,
that's cool.
Shit.
God,
did he really say that it's got his black belt in TV?
Let me tell you if he got fired from Fox by the though of course you did.
Yeah.
The dirty little secret is about all those guys.
They don't know what the fuck they're doing.
They find talented people.
They have no idea.
If you get still should be doing that.
Yeah.
If you get fucking Max Kellerman,
you get all those guys.
Those are the guys that are on your television show.
The television show was going to do well.
If those are the guys that are doing commentary for you,
they're excellent.
They're compelling,
you're going to listen to it.
You're not a great producer.
That's not why the show's great.
No,
it was talent.
You fucks.
Yeah.
When you're telling them a podcast,
the one free medium left on the planet earth.
When you can distribute to millions of people and no one can tell you what the
fuck to do.
There's not another thing like it on earth.
Not One,
not one,
maybe websites,
but it's [inaudible] content you can get.
Yeah,
and to be able to have that with no producer,
no executive,
no filter,
and to have it available to you while you're doing other stuff.
Right.
You could be mowing your lawn right now.
It's in your ear.
You're running,
it's in your ear.
You're driving to work.
It's in your ear.
You're on the subway.
It's in your,
no people too.
Like if,
let's say you were a 2019 Jay Leno,
that's what you were at this like doing the shows as grilling,
doing Johnny Carson at the time,
right.
Let's say you're that guy that states that overproduced show.
No one really gets to know.
Did you know Johnny Carson from the tonight show?
Do you know Jay Leno?
No.
It's one when they went on to do stuff after the fact,
but now people know you pretty fucking well,
people know me pretty well.
Pretty well.
Yeah.
You're not on board or you're not.
Yeah,
it's different.
It's different.
But even Conan talked about that,
how,
you know when he was doing the cone and I heard my Howard stern and he was
doing,
he said,
well I do the Conan show and you know,
we had a band and it would,
I was going through this interview,
but at the stop it like I was in balls deep in this interview,
man,
I have to stop it because the band's playing.
We've got to get to that.
Or we go to the next bit and he's like,
no,
no.
Just let me go,
man.
Let me have this conversation.
So he's even come over to podcasting and even Howard stern goes,
well that's one of the reasons I want to do long form is because they want to
overproduce all this stuff.
But if I,
if I have to get to,
you know,
I want to talk to somebody,
I want to get to know him.
I don't want to cut to commercial breaks.
I don't have to cut for this band or this bit.
You want to do,
let me talk to this guy,
man.
Well there's a lot of guys that are still cutting their podcast off with
commercials.
They'll stop in the middle and do a commercial.
Do you guys do that?
Uh,
we've done it before.
I don't know if we currently do.
We just left.
Um,
our current advertisers was a nightmare.
We just signed with paragon,
shout it to paragon.
So,
um,
you know,
I don't know,
sometimes we might,
sometimes you might Joe,
to be honest with you,
but you know what we are doing,
if you're going to do it,
you're only going to do it once,
right?
Once.
Yeah.
But what's different with king in this thing is so when we do our read,
I don't you guys do it before and there's no video,
but we do it mean Theo do it together on camera and have fun with it.
So it's part of the show,
different animals.
Theo doing a read for it.
I don't wanna read for this financial thing and he goes and you can save I think
$75 a year.
And I,
when I said $75 a year,
you know I didn't preread I $75 I cut a crack.
And then Theo goes,
yeah,
a smooth $75 a year.
You go dude.
And financial people get mad at you.
I don't know.
I don't give a fuck.
We were laughing so hard.
I go,
yeah,
go with him.
Get $75 is that really what they're offering?
And forget 70 7,575 but well,
7,500 different dif.
I forget what it was,
but yeah,
it was something super low and I could not stop laughing.
Then Theo start laughing.
They left it in.
I feel like that reed would do better than than the others maybe,
but it would be too.
It would do better in terms of financial,
I mean a about in terms of clicks,
but it probably wouldn't do better in terms of people like going there and using
the product.
[inaudible] funny,
great.
They don't matter.
It doesn't matter.
We've got,
we'll find someone else.
Yeah.
That's the thing.
It's like an animal.
You have too many podcast sponsors who's days I'd say no to him every day.
I get
tons of them coming in.
Yeah,
I bet.
But it's not.
It's got to make some sense Peskin that connect with what you're going to be a
good thing too.
It's like gotta be a valuable product.
Yeah.
You gave me the best advice ever when when I started doing uh,
advertising on podcasts because there's a while before we started doing it.
You better believe in it,
man.
You Sell Shit people and stop tuning in.
They're not going to believe you.
I've had a bunch of things that I turned down because I w I researched it and I
was like,
what is this?
How does that work?
Yeah,
Brian's great at that.
And I was like,
oh,
this is sketchy.
There was one of them.
They want to do an Uber for babysitting.
I'm like,
yet,
that's a fuck here out of here,
don't you?
Crazy.
The biggest argument Cowan I ever gotten,
I fucking 90 year relationship is burger king came towards us and I,
I grew up eating burger king,
man.
I grew up in a whopper with cheese.
Not every day,
but I'd fucking have one.
We've got them American.
Brian said,
no.
Yeah.
He's like,
we can't push that off.
And we got in the straight up argument.
How did end?
Uh,
I think we did burger king rate.
Shout out to Burger King.
They're hungry and they're open.
Yeah.
Fucking a whopper with cheese.
The Best Burger on planet earth that fuck you in the now that's not true.
So not true.
Catch up.
Only take you to a doctor right now and get a cat scan.
You like [inaudible] fucking double from in and out.
Side note,
I can't do and then on day two or five guys,
burgers fabric or five guys over in it now,
but we can agree on one thing.
I told them guys,
Nazis,
not five,
not,
not in and out.
What's in it for a number one much for number one.
I like five guys and I look in and out like five guys.
Number one though.
Yeah,
I think I like five guys better because five guys offers bacon and also
Jalapenos.
I'm not just water the speed of in and out of such deterrent to sometimes it
takes a long time.
How dare you.
The one right up here.
Well five guys,
doesn't that drive through though,
right?
Five guys doesn't do the drive.
They're like pitch,
sit down,
come on in and they have milkshakes at in and out.
That's a big plus.
If you're ready to fuck your body up,
it's poisoned food that tastes great.
Depth shakes,
shakes,
do it to you till they'll give it to you.
Dude,
I've been so stressed out with this special ed.
My Diet.
You work out to crate my diet.
All that.
Get girls pregnant.
Yeah.
Pickles and ice cream and shit.
She's like,
girl might be pregnant again.
She tired.
Um,
yeah man.
Been eating pizza every night.
Oh,
I don't know what it is,
dude.
It's no fun.
I'm going to fuck dude.
Old Stress.
They've actually said that the people under stress make poor decisions.
Poor decisions,
cheating.
Everything was to really,
yeah.
People.
People make poor decisions.
Foodwise I did buy a front end of eat pizza every night.
Maybe you might be on to something.
Yeah,
I think you're a,
you're freaking out.
Not freaking out though.
A little bit.
You think it's okay and we'll figure that normal.
No,
no.
You're not freaking out,
but you're under stress.
You Look [inaudible] I'm getting judged by hundreds of thousands of people's.
Very weird.
It's weird.
Yeah.
And every time I do it,
I stay offline for weeks.
Yeah.
That's what you told me to stay offline.
Can read it.
Like I do my best.
I try hard.
I do my best.
And you might like it.
You might not like it,
but I do my best and when I'm done,
as long as I know I did my best,
I can just release it.
I've been able to do that for triggered and I did that for a strange time.
Switched over.
I was like,
I'm good,
I'm good.
I mean,
you might like,
you might not like it,
but I couldn't have done it better.
You don't mind.
Thing is,
is,
uh,
the,
I think with anything as you get more popular with,
with its do podcasting or stand up or whatever you do,
if you're an artist you put on the album for,
you're paying your pet out of painting.
If you're a fighter to take a flight,
it's a big fight on your track.
More eyeballs.
You can get a lot more people that love it.
Then you,
a lot of you can get more hate because you're out there more.
So also you being shoved down people's faces.
Yeah.
Because you're going to do a lot of press.
Yeah,
man.
That's why I don't do press.
It's one of the reasons why I know you gotta love.
You don't have to.
I don't do,
I don't want to,
I don't want anybody to have to listen to me.
I don't,
I don't want you had such a different level than I have.
I have to do.
I know,
I guess a little bit,
you know what I'm saying?
But I don't do it for stand up anymore.
When I go to towns,
I'm not depressed anymore.
Beautiful.
But when you're getting 100% your fans.
Yes.
And also with,
with the special,
it's different because I didn't want like our group,
like you guys who vouched for me or especially show time,
who was like,
let's give to kids.
Especially,
I didn't want to embarrass embarrassed.
I want it to go well for them.
Like,
you know?
Yeah,
no,
no.
What you're saying.
Like I want them back.
All right,
we're proud of this,
which they are.
So I should be good with that.
You know?
And I know you guys are proud of me,
so I should be good with that.
Just provide,
give a fuck you,
you're,
you're trying to get better with something that's very difficult to do.
Some say the most difficult than,
than you put out a special two years in,
which is ridiculous.
I told you not to do it.
Of course you wanted to come to me with,
uh,
but uh,
but yeah,
I knew you were going to do it.
So you guys know me.
I mean we went down there and we helped you out.
We opened for you.
We,
you know,
it was time.
It was a great time and you're going to look back on it like in eight years from
now when you have a,
another killer special out,
well you don't like or several down the line.
Yeah.
When you think you'll do another one,
do you think you wait another two years?
Like have you thought about three years before I was talking to week?
I don't mean to interrupt you.
I think it's sweet.
Cool to look back and go,
holy fuck yous three years in this way he did.
And then four years from now,
see the progression for your phone and see the progression.
Yes.
And you can go back and look.
I think that's to me fucking cool,
man.
Yeah.
Oh,
100%.
Yeah.
Listen,
man,
there's some videos me from when I first started out,
they're terrible.
There's no way you're not going to be,
you're going to be terrible.
Yes sir.
You're,
you're just learning how to do something again.
It's like judging your roles when you a wipe out versus your roles as a black
for sure.
It's like you don't know what you're doing.
Yeah.
You're fucking flailing around.
It's real similar.
Yep.
That's fine,
man.
It's,
it's,
uh,
were you gonna say though about specials most?
Most,
like especially seasoned once every,
I think three years.
What Kevin say for why I was gonna say Jessalyn Nick Jeff's neck has a really
interesting thought process on it and he was telling me that he does,
he did the podcast recently.
I love him,
by the way.
I do too.
He's great.
He's fucks a comptroller,
man.
Outstanding.
He's a new special fasten.
Yeah.
And it's on Netflix.
It's available right now.
Just came out amazing.
What's it called?
Thoughts and prayers is that it?
I think sell thoughts in pairs.
Um,
anyway,
that might be his other one.
He's about several,
but his new one just dropped on Netflix like a few weeks ago.
Yeah.
I don't think it's thoughts and purse.
I think thoughts or personal fire in the maternity ward.
Close fire in the maternity ward.
So what he does is he works on the material for a year,
like in La.
He just does like little,
little sets here and there and publish together,
puts together his hour.
Then he takes his hour on the road and does clubs for a year.
Just clubs from one year to,
then he does theaters for a year,
three and at the end of that year he films,
so every three years,
which is not a bad idea if you don't get tired of your shit.
The problem as you do a lot of sets,
like I'll do four sets a night.
Sometimes I get really tired.
Your Shit,
I get tired.
I get tired of new bits.
Yeah.
Especially during that many times.
Doe?
Yes.
It's hard.
It's hard to stay motivated the same bit.
Yeah.
But it's also,
look,
I feel so lucky that I can do it.
I feel so lucky.
Like every time I go to do a set,
like I went to the store last night and hanging out in the back would
Fitzsimmons and Ian Edwards and Owen Smith,
who I'm trying to convince Owen Smith and never write again cause I think he's
the fucking own Smith Cambridge up to do you gotta come see him.
That guy's a monster.
She burst.
So Goshen the other night he sighed.
Oh and Smith is so good and he's got this gig where he's,
he's,
he's always writing,
but there's an,
there's a writer's strike right now is he's a ride for like a major series,
Tom's and shit.
But dude,
his stand ups out of control.
So he came with us to that super nice dude.
He's the bass.
Really Nice.
Super.
So it that a little Josh Martin,
Josh,
she's fucking charge to cheeto.
Santina was fucking amazing.
That was a killer show.
We did two shows at the Improv.
We're doing more of those too.
He ends up fucking gain.
Kids are killer to the rider too.
Yep.
Same deal.
Same,
same deal.
And I tried to talk to him about it to,
Ian's been on the road with me for years and years.
He opened for me when I did triggered,
he took,
I've taken them on the road for years.
He's amazing.
This guy in the world nights,
he's so nice to him.
Nicest guy.
Someone Santina.
Santina was a nice,
he's a man's man.
Santiago,
that guy.
I love that going.
Let me to have a close bond was in shut up a cheeto.
Um,
you know who I podcast?
Tiger Bell.
I did with Bobby Lee.
I told him,
I said,
you owe,
you owe it to comedy.
Do a fucking special man.
At least 30 minutes.
And he goes,
and he goes,
I think,
I think that's my broken.
Won't have me on.
He's disappointed in me.
I went,
I just think you get your shit together.
Do a specialist.
Well,
that's not true that it won't have mine.
Every time I say,
Oh,
do you want to come on my podcast?
He runs away.
He's sleeping,
he gets panicky.
Well he doesn't wake up to one,
but he gets panicky.
I don't know why.
He's a great dude.
He's got stuff in his head that shouldn't be in there.
It's also smart dude.
He has a lot to say.
Oh yeah,
I love Bobby.
Right on here,
dude.
I've been friends with Bobby Lee's since [inaudible] 96 it's been a commie for a
hot second.
That dude forever just started doing economy thing cause I'll start,
let me kill this trip club in San Diego.
That's what we started in Mexican gang bangers with tattoos on their face and
long black hair.
Bobby Lee's trying to tell the girlfriend to give him a lap dance and I had to
grab him and drag him the fuck out of here.
I'm like,
listen to me,
Bobby,
listen to me.
Those guys are serious.
We gotta get the fuck out of here now.
And he's like,
fuck those guys are here to do shit.
And I'm like,
I will fucking leave you here.
I'm like,
I'm going.
I jumped in my super turbo and we fucking hauled ass out of there and Bobby
leaves in the backseat.
I was like,
probably shut the fuck up.
They were going to kill you.
You have no idea.
I'm like a certain dudes.
You looked him in the eye and you go,
oh,
this guy's for real.
They got the eyes great white shark.
Yeah.
And like,
look,
I'm not the most street smart dude.
I'm not saying that,
but I can read a room though.
I can read predators.
Yeah.
I've been around a lot of fucking stone cold killers in my life and now I saw
that guy and I was like,
oh,
okay sir.
I'm gonna just take my little friend and stuff from the back seat of my fucking
Japanese car and peel out of here.
Is it Toyota Supra?
Yeah,
Dude.
It was scary.
Bobby was so ridiculous.
So you're not gonna do shit.
I'm like,
oh Jesus Christ.
I was like,
get in the fucking car,
man.
Come on.
So fun.
You gotta get Outta here.
That was my introduction to Bobby Lee because he was working at the La Jolla
comedies because it saves a door guy.
That's how he started.
I don't even remember how we wound up at that fucking strip club because like
all I remember was like the world zoomed in,
like goes looking at it through a a toilet paper roll a group and I'm looking at
this Mexican gang banger who stood up with his hands out there like this and,
and Bobby Lee is act like it's not a big deal.
I'm like,
oh my God,
we're gonna die holy photos like that.
Just moments where you like,
you almost get hit by a car.
Like that's,
that's what it felt like.
I was like,
oh my God,
Bobby.
Like that guy's a real criminal.
Like this.
We gotta get Outta here.
And his girl was one of the dancers and Bobby was apparently trying to get his
girl to give him a lap dance.
Oh,
we ran out of there,
man.
We fucking hauled ass.
I drove very fast and I got off the first exit and I turned around and went back
the other way.
Just in case someone was following me,
I was making sure no one was following me.
Jesus.
I was like,
this is real.
Bobby.
Bobby's hilarious.
We were talking about La Jolla comedy club.
I was telling how like specialists to me clinically,
no stuff about staying in the condo.
And I was,
I would go,
oh,
it was great because they have redundant and Jim Carrey state there and he's my
hero.
So you know,
for me,
especially us,
man,
we have a deal.
He goes,
I wish I had the same kind of admiration for that,
that comedy store in La Jolla Condo.
He goes,
cause when I was there,
uh,
I forget the comic stained with some gay comic.
He goes,
he,
they used to take like 14 dudes back there and run trains and come all over the
walls.
He goes,
that's why the walls were blue for a long time.
Went,
oh,
I don't know if that's true.
He says,
Christ Bobby.
I don't know if that's true.
[inaudible] it's a lot of these,
a lot of adding to that,
you know,
maybe there's just one guy named on God on the wall.
You guys came in,
you guys and sandy are running the tray.
It's not that far fetched.
Yeah.
You don't have to say,
do you know who the hodge twins are?
Yes,
they do.
You know about it?
Comment.
They have to,
they have a fucking,
there's a,
they were reading an article about men getting pregnant like that.
Women aren't the only ones who can get pregnant
because the way they talk,
you know,
you know the way they talk,
their big old Jack Dudes,
you know,
and I'm on the podcast interview and they get seriously amped up,
but they were talking about busting a nut inside of Dude's ass.
You cannot get them pregnant about how deep you go in that man's anus and
they're the same.
They're like,
yeah,
they talk fucking like,
because dude,
because people are saying some crazy shit.
That's not,
that's a crazy,
yes,
yes.
This is a real argument.
You know,
Yale started putting tampons.
Dispensers,
get the fuck in the men's room because they said,
not everyone who menstruates is a woman.
Hi.
Welcome to the upside down world.
Wow.
Did you ever,
uh,
did you ever watch a stranger thrilling come to Trump's for this?
What you were watched stranger things?
Fuck yeah.
I love that.
We're in the opposite down.
The world is upside down right now.
That's what's happening.
So disciplined,
flipped over to the other side.
People are getting,
they're so progressive.
They're literally denying science for PR for feelings.
Do you feel like a woman then you're a woman.
Fuck,
I gave her identify as a woman.
Do you feel like a man will then you're a man.
Amazing man,
Bro.
Congratulations.
You're going to make the best mom,
dad,
whatever the fuck did I ever dad,
mom,
these dudes are coming and dude's ass and say they can pray.
It's a funny,
it's a funny little thing that they did.
Did you find it?
I was looking for it.
They made me,
I stumbled across that mouth they just talked about which was you just talking.
They're all over youtube there.
What does this meet the formerly transgender man who now identifies as a
genderless alien.
Oh yeah,
I seen that.
Did.
We showed that guy before his surgery and shit
set a bunch of surgery to look like an alien.
I don't give a fuck.
Just don't force it on me that I'd have to,
if I fuck him,
call you a him.
Yeah.
I say congratulations to them.
Yeah,
there you go.
You've made it.
Congrats man.
A lot of people want to be special,
but they don't want to work for it.
And the problem with that is you get that kind of shit.
You get people that are pretending to be something super special to get
attention so they get attention and you're not doing anything and there's
nothing there.
You know what I really love?
I had Eddie Izzard on who's,
uh,
probably one of the most famous transgender people ever and just,
I did a search engine.
I saw your picture.
Just decided.
He,
that's what he likes.
And we,
once you get past that and just talk to him,
he's amazing humans.
A human man.
He's amazing.
I don't care what I care is,
when you say crazy things like men can get pregnant,
that's insane.
That's not real.
Have you had crested back,
done the navy and was running for governor.
I don't know what she's doing now,
but we cal and I went to lunch with her afterwards and normal shit man.
Normal also talked like bike,
like you might go when you were in battle this and just talks like,
like a fucking human because he only give a fuck.
Yeah.
All right.
You want to wear a dress?
Yeah.
Everyone's looking at you cause you got the physique of me and he got a fucking
miniskirt on.
All right.
Whatever.
Who Cares?
Who gives a fuck you and once you get used to it,
like you're used to the way people dress,
period.
Yes.
You used to everything.
You know,
it's just nonsense.
It's nonsense.
Like I don't care.
As long as you're not hurting me,
you're hurting someone else.
I don't want cash in it on care.
Don't push it on.
Betty is there and say what?
Like he always felt like that this is a man can have babies now
areas by the way,
look got angry,
shut up to the Hodgkin's tobacco play this.
Jamie,
can we play it or we get pulled?
We'll probably get some Twitter.
We'll get pulled.
Nah,
no,
no.
It's their show here.
The volume.
Just hear the audio though and just,
no,
no.
We'll just tell people what is the,
just decides men can have babies now and it's on their youtube.
You can we hear it really broke copyright laws.
No,
it doesn't matter.
We don't have to edit it out later.
Haters,
haters.
It's just look,
you tubes in a weird place right now in terms of copyright and we've gotten
claims on us for watching something on a screen in the background.
Like you see a picture in a picture and you,
you don't even hear it.
And they want all the ad revenue for the entire show.
How about the LG?
That's ridiculous.
So Erin,
how about the,
when the combine guy,
we're talking about his dick that got flagged when I was like,
Hey,
she's dick popped out for tack for nudity.
Yeah,
I come on,
come on his fucking Dick.
You have to have hopped out and you'd have to pause it and just go frame by
frame and go,
is that the desk kind of pixelated and they sound there for half a second.
Don't even know what you're looking at if I don't tell you.
And well,
what youtube is doing is making a boatload of cash.
They know what they're doing.
Oh my God,
I just don't run the way they run the world.
Well between Facebook,
youtube,
Twitter,
Instagram,
youtube,
Facebook owns Instagram.
No,
they all in the world.
Look,
Facebook is changing elections.
Facebook is influencing the way the world votes.
Did you hear what they're going to start doing with the,
I think it's Instagram.
They're going to start.
Uh,
you can,
as the user,
you're,
you're owner of your own page,
but the rest of the world can't see your followers and likes.
Huh.
That's interesting because kids in high school and I then I can with a three
year old son.
It's scary worlds was social media,
I'm sure with your daughters,
you can understand is people suicide,
especially in teenage girls has never been higher because they're putting so
much,
so much weighs on their social media.
So how many followers,
how many likes they get,
so we get rid of that might help.
Well,
you know,
they're reaching the same kind of people that we're talking about.
We're talking about haters,
but they're reaching it like local,
like their friends and people from school and they're shitting on each other and
being mean to each other and they don't understand what that does to a person
yet they don't have compassion the way a grown adult has.
When they understand they have perspective,
they understand what kind of emotional influence it's going to have on a person.
When you shit on him like that,
I've seen it happen,
man.
It's not pretty.
But also like when you and I were bullied,
especially you back in the day when you're bullied,
you could go home,
you'd think about it,
but you didn't have to constantly get it all.
If your daughter's been bullied at school?
Well,
she goes home at three o'clock and now it's on the Maya and then they gang up
and then this person from another school gangs up in this person from Ohio,
gangs up and then they're all fucking taken fire.
I've seen them play little games with each other too.
It's weird.
It's weird watching kids play little emotional head games with each other.
I was like,
Jesus Christ,
like people are button pushers,
right?
They see a button,
they push it,
they want to see what it does and they find out does something.
They want to push it again,
make it do that thing again.
When you find out you can make someone upset,
you press their buttons.
You know there's girlfriends do that.
Boyfriends do that.
Friends,
lovers,
family members,
people press buttons.
But I've had family members that would do that.
They would just press buttons just to fuck with you and I.
But even on social media,
it's like people can press buttons if you,
if you let them know that that button gets to you.
Right?
I,
I never,
I never punched down.
So if the,
if it's a guy with an egg for an Avatar,
so,
and I don't know,
I never ever very rarely I've punched down or coming back and an average,
that's what they want.
Right.
What's interesting to me is it affects people like Kevin Duran who's possibly
the best basketball player on planet earth and he just got into a Twitter war
with just like he's been known to have fake accounts,
burner accounts defending himself online,
caught doing that.
He this,
this um,
this guy who works a commentator and Alice for Fox was like,
oh,
critiquing him,
he started firing back at him.
Then another guy like a troll with 55 followers talk shit to,
he fires back.
What are you doing?
But here's the,
here's the message with them.
I see all that.
I'm like,
God,
what the fuck is he doing?
I'm like,
Holy Fuck.
If Kevin Duran,
who's worth $600 million,
the best basketball player on planet earth,
if it affects him,
what do you think a 13 year old girl with body issues is feeling?
Like that's what's scary.
Yeah.
Or Boy,
boy or girl says kids are the suicide with teenage girls is a lot.
Have you ever read Jonathan hates books on that?
Jonathan Haidt who he's been on my podcast,
Cowen knows him,
I think maybe can talk to him too,
I believe.
But uh,
he wrote a book called the coddling of the American mind and part of the book
was about the influence of social media and what is happening when Itunes,
a couple of years ago.
Yeah.
Maybe a year.
I'll be here a pretty recent because you'd have to be up to date to know he's a
shit.
He's brilliant.
I really enjoyed talking to him.
It's um,
it's one of those things where you go,
yeah,
this is nothing that were designed for.
It's not normal.
You know,
when girls talk shit about you across the,
you know,
like you see them across the breezeway,
like you're walking to your classroom,
they're over there and they're talking shit about you.
Like fuck those bitches.
Put,
if they're saying it online and you read it on a Facebook page that her ankles
are fat,
fucking loser.
Get that nose job,
lol and kids will do shit like that until we job lol.
Yeah,
kids will do shit like that to each other,
but if you read it now all of a sudden an impact.
Is it real?
It becomes re it hits you in a way that it doesn't hit you.
If you see them talking shit,
if I see some dudes talking shit about me and they're over there,
I'm like you or you really took to,
what do you do?
What about feel good,
feel good,
insulting people.
Fucking loses.
Concentrate in your own life.
Get your shit together about online.
Like you ever go to une,
you've never read a comment like I've read comments before,
but I don't read them anymore.
Did it affect you?
It affected me when I first started being on the Internet,
but over the course of my being on the Internet,
I've learned how to not emotionally engaged chalices well did you just learn
bullshit?
It's calluses.
What people are like.
If I've done something that was poor and it wasn't good and someone said that
sucked,
it burns.
But you know why burns cause they're right.
True.
Cause they're right.
Yeah.
When that happens that's,
that's an opportunity to get better.
That's what that is.
That's an opportunity to look at yourself to reassess,
start from scratch,
just look at it with fresh renewed vigor and understanding that the negative
consequences of failing or doing poorly or you know,
just not putting enough attention to turning on.
What do you mean?
Like lately you're not,
I'm sure what's the last thing you did that you got negative but it doesn't
matter.
That's how I looked at it.
It's like,
but that's one of the reasons why cause I'm always tweaking it like that and
I'll have sets that are off and a lot of the times it sets that are off cause
I'm experimenting with Shit,
I'm moving stuff around,
you know,
doesn't matter.
But it does.
Wow.
I don't like it.
I don't like,
like people go,
no,
no.
When I don't do well I'm not,
I'm not listening to what other people are saying.
I'm my own worst critic.
You have to,
so yeah.
Yeah.
So the bottom line is if they're wrong,
like if someone says something in there wrong,
it's like I don't care.
Like it doesn't bother me.
If you say mean things and you're wrong,
I don't care.
But if your right eye care and the reason why cares cause I haven't done a good
job so I care more about what I've failed at,
then the person's opinions,
they can't be all invested in that.
People's opinions that people you don't know because everyone's words look the
same when they're typed out.
Like you don't get to see if there was like an an intelligence quotient and
emotional intelligence and social intelligence.
If you could find out how to stir up somebody was by the text just looking at
it,
you'd get a better understanding of whether or not you should listen to this
person's opinion.
Yeah.
When you just look at text,
it could be it's very black and white.
Yeah.
I mean it could be Cornell rest wrote that or it could be fucking Richard
Spencer Rhoda.
It's just words like it doesn't,
you don't convey who the person is from those words.
It's very difficult.
So someone can say something insulting or Shitty.
Do you designed to try to get you.
They're just trying to hope to get you.
Why?
Why do you,
why do you think it's such an,
why do you think you get it?
I don't get to do get it.
I guess they're helpless.
They're helpless.
So that's why there's so much negativity.
Yes.
That's of the reason why it shouldn't be a positive atmosphere for some,
you're positive.
You have a fucking Ferrari,
you live in a mansion.
It's easier.
A handsome guy,
you 10 feet tall.
It's all good things.
It's got a giant take here.
You've got big Dick Energy.
It's all right.
All these things are full.
Also worked for,
you didn't work for that deck.
I was born with this thing.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
It's a,
for some things,
I'm sure it is.
Poor boy you had,
you've had many good brakes.
Some people have had none.
Some people have had none and they also have a phone and they have a Twitter
account and they're like,
fuck you.
Yeah,
but fuck you in your further.
That's while you're still Q in your mansion.
Yeah.
Fuck you.
And everything you stand for because they can't see a real path.
Like if you're standing there,
but that's why they're a loser because you cause you're getting online,
you spewing out hate cause you're not happy with your lawyer.
They're 17 like they don't get it yet.
Let's say they're not a lot,
but there's a lot of that.
Where are 17 they used to be a loser at 17 now they're 27 and nothing's gotten
much better.
There's a lot of that going on.
Instagram and shitting on someone who's successful is going to get you to where
you want to go.
No,
unless you're really funny.
There are people that just do a comp.
Yeah.
There is some kind of juicy,
you'll have a section where we,
we read off the people roasting us.
We need it back and forth to each other.
People are good.
Some people,
Hillary,
most are awful.
There's,
there's people that have like formulated a comedy career from Dunkin on folks
online,
right?
Yeah.
But that'd be a Jenny Johnson,
Jenny Johnson high five.
It's like,
that'd be the minority though.
Yeah.
But if you're a good writer,
here's the thing.
The world is not,
it's like good ideas and good writing and being funny.
It's not exclusive to professionals.
There's a lot of people out there who are really funny,
who never figured out a way to,
to do capitalize on it.
Yeah.
Look,
dude,
when I was a fucking open miker when I was first starting out,
I worked for a guy named Dave Dolan.
He's dead now.
He's a private investigator.
To this day,
one of the funniest fucking dudes I've ever met in my life,
who we used to call him dynamite.
Dickless Dave Dolan,
who was an animal it,
oh,
hold on,
hold on.
Dynamite.
Ticketless Day triple d.
He died a few years back,
but he's one of the rare people that I save his voice mails.
Now you save people's voicemails.
I used to after they're dead.
Yeah.
Like I,
I,
he's one of those guys.
I'm never fucking delete.
How'd he pass away?
Listen to this.
I can't wait.
Oh,
Derek was very rare.
Dickless Dave here.
How Boston is that,
Liz?
Just,
it's hard to hear it because I can't put it on speaker.
Dave here.
Why does it not go on speaker?
What did he pass away from?
Ah,
you got cancer.
Joe.
Derek was very rare.
Joe,
your comedy still funny as a mother fucker.
He's so modest.
He left me this long email or a voicemail,
but I never delete that.
He's,
yeah,
I love that guy forever.
But he,
when we were friends,
when he was alive,
he,
I always said,
why don't you do comedy?
Well,
how the fuck are you not a Canadian?
He was one of the finest human beings I've ever,
like Joey Diaz level.
Funny.
He was.
So we do it just didn't have the balls.
You liked being a private investigator,
like busting people.
He got a kick out of,
it was a game for him that works for him and his brother or his cousin rather.
It was Billy Downs and Billy Downs owned the comedy connection.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
So we had an N.
Could he is easier than for most people.
When I started working for him,
I had no idea that he was Billy Downs cousin.
I responded to an ad in a newspaper where a private investigator needed an
assistant and I was like,
what a great,
what a great job like as you try to be a comedian,
be it private investigators assistant is going to be awesome,
but what he really needed was a driver.
He lost his license from driving while intoxicated.
Okay.
He's awesome.
He was the best,
but he quit.
He quit booze.
Fucking cold Turkey right then and there and didn't go to meetings and do any of
that shit.
Just quit gangster.
Oh Man.
He was a beautiful person,
but he was one of the funniest people I've ever met in my life.
That guy,
if he had Twitter and he would just want to dunk on people,
he would have been fucking you up,
man.
You would have read his shit and fall on the ground laughing.
He was just funny.
It's funny.
People are just funny.
Funny is not exclusive.
Sessionals call you are,
you aren't,
you can cultivate it.
I know some comedians that weren't that good and they got way,
way,
way better,
but I'm sure they were.
But be the comedian then also being funny in person.
That little bit of difference different.
Yeah.
There's some guys just,
they're just funny.
Like Richard,
Jenny,
who's in my mind,
one of the best comedians of all time.
He was always real somber in person.
Like it's never,
it was never really serious who's depressed,
which is why he killed himself.
He just wasn't happy,
wasn't just a little uncomfortable in his own skin.
And there's comedians like that now,
even at this store.
Oh yeah.
You meet them.
You're like,
Oh wow,
you're,
you're very serious.
Come up Brody.
You know,
Brody mean he wasn't that serious or at least around me the few times when I was
around him.
He,
he was fun.
He can't dark.
Can we get dark enough?
I can pretend I did.
He was always very cool.
Yeah.
I mean,
I think guys like you and I,
um,
one thing,
especially coming from athletics,
coming from martial arts,
you're,
uh,
more likely to like suck it up and you're more likely to not give in to the
negative demons and you're also more likely to exercise regularly.
You're more likely to,
so when you see someone who's struggling with something they shouldn't be
struggling with,
you're like,
but you're frustrated.
You're good though.
It's frustrating from doubt.
You're fucking,
you're really good.
Like if you are doing really good as a comic,
you know,
you'll call me up and you'll say pro fucking killed tonight was amazed.
Like I had such a great set of it.
That's great.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
It's not bragging.
No,
no,
no.
It's happiness.
It's happy to tell you,
cause I know you relate to it.
So Brody,
who was a murderer,
you could never say he was great.
You would never say like,
Brody,
you fucking kill me.
If he would,
he would like skirt around here.
Like Rogen always supportive.
Rogan.
Yeah,
they always fled to flood zone would always deflect it.
He never,
I don't think he wanted to,
I don't think he wanted to accept the fact that people loved them.
Like when you know,
when he had it would have a great set.
It would almost like it wouldn't elevate him.
Like some guys get off steel like Hinchcliffe Hinchcliffe a murder I'll get off
stage will be like,
Woo.
Yeah,
you'll come to your,
you're the Kaiser.
His eyes would be giant will high five everybody,
he's feeling it,
you know.
But Brody didn't get like that.
And I'm not saying feels the same in any regards to what Brody was suffering
with,
but you know,
Theo has his demons,
whatever you need.
It's very,
it's out there.
I'm not outing feels the same way where he'll do a set and I'm like,
dude,
that is one of the best things I've ever seen,
man.
Be like,
get the fuck,
stop.
Get the fuck [inaudible] on.
I'm telling you,
it's so good,
dude.
I,
it's a version of it feels got his own version.
It's not as extreme as everyone has their monsters.
Yeah.
But like a guy like you or me,
we're very,
you're goal oriented.
You see,
you try and get better at things.
You see things.
That's how you got good at Jujitsu.
It's like I could have fighting until you get good at comedy.
Everything you want to get good at,
you get good at.
By focusing on it and setting goals and trying to get better and better.
And when you do get better,
you celebrate.
You enjoy it.
It's fun,
it's exciting.
Some people don't get that feeling,
man.
They don't,
they don't ever get those highs and those highs just don't exist.
So it's,
and for me,
you know what,
what,
what gets me more than anything now is new stuff.
What gets me more than anything,
it's creation.
It's like those little things you come up with those nuggets.
Like if you knew walk and show and a walkway go,
oh fuck,
how come the back go,
dude,
I wrote down with killed.
I'm like,
Oh my God,
you're recording right?
Yeah.
I can run with that.
So there's something there.
Yeah.
Then I'll walk away on like the highest time,
man.
It's amazing.
No shows.
What's interesting is hanging around you as much as I have is,
um,
you're,
you're serious.
But you and I are more similar than like me or delete or me and Callan.
Callan dalea show silly all the time.
Delay might be funny or off stage.
He's amazing onstage,
but he's so funny offstage.
Brian is so fun now stage where they're constantly on like they get around,
they mess around all the time and you're like,
you don't have to be that way.
I thought for the lungs I had to act that way because that's the way cause I
hung out with Brian and Kevin and dilly is so much and like this I don't want to
do,
like I just want to chill and do my set and then talk about cars or whatever and
it gives a fuck out.
It'd be myself.
That's,
yeah,
I'm not them.
I don't want to have to be on and fuck around all day.
I don't like fuck around all the time.
We'll delete your,
the only one who they avoid like real conversations.
They don't talk,
they just fake insult each other.
Yeah,
they just insult each other.
Where I'm like,
all right,
well,
all right.
What else man?
Like I was lying.
Did Collin got boxing mitts made that have faced?
That's fake.
That's on someone put it on Photoshop.
Those on there.
That's amazing.
They did a great job.
It's hilarious though.
I thought he actually hadn't.
Mits made a,
I was like fuck to them,
but those guys are shut that like that's,
that's who they are.
Their count.
If it's a room of three or 30 he's going to entertain him.
He's the,
he's the,
you know the,
the clown.
That's why I took them hunting.
That's not me,
man.
That's not,
that's not what I wanted to do.
I want to talk to you.
Either ask about your family and then go on stage and be flooding.
Looking at them.
They're your prime count.
Ron Punches like a guy who's never been punched.
You said,
oh,
maybe that.
Maybe those are real.
I think you're right.
You're right.
You're right brother.
He just,
no way can we fake.
Whenever I see cal hidden Mitts,
I fast forward.
I go to the next page.
I know.
He's so silly.
He's so sassy getting into boxing at 80 years old.
Look at this and it keeps telling me his shoulders are fine.
I'm like,
well,
why are you punching so slow then if your shoulders are fine,
what is wrong?
Like are you in a room with thick air?
He's obsessed with it.
Like what is happening at high altitude?
Why is the tide the altitude?
If there's no attitude,
at least your hands would move quicker.
That's real.
Do you know that?
That that's with ballistics.
With archery,
you shoot high and high altitude.
Oh really?
Yes,
because there's less drag.
That makes sense.
There's less air.
Why is his hands moving so slow?
He's to be so sad.
Weird.
He's been boxing with with private lessons for a while.
He goes,
Wayne thinks,
ah,
you know,
I could probably fight pro.
I went talent.
I would count on your pain.
That man money.
Dot.
I love Wayne Talk.
Here's the problem.
I say you're 57 years old and you're paying that man money,
so if you went Callen you look terrible,
you're going to go,
well,
you're the one coaching me.
So,
of course I went,
let me ask you something.
You play tennis,
right?
He goes,
yeah,
what you hit with a pro,
right?
He goes,
yeah,
I went,
you pay him right and go.
Has He ever told you he thinks she could maybe compete us?
Yeah,
that's what they do because they got to show progress and hype you up.
Otherwise,
if he's like,
dude,
you're awful.
Never fight again.
You're not gonna keep paying them.
Dude,
in a great though.
That's Callan,
this just people.
It's talent in a nutshell.
It's just great people that do that.
Their coach you that blow smoke up your ass.
Gotta be super careful.
Those Su pretty careful Eddie's students had this guy who was,
he was a Jujitsu guy and uh,
he was fighting in the UFC and this coach is Moitai coach was like,
he's Bangkok ready?
He's,
and I was like,
Whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
Like as a striker.
I was like,
no,
he's not like,
what are you talking about?
Like the,
they blow smoke,
they get a fat,
one of these Tommy Chong joints firecracker.
Look at this joint.
It's a firecracker from this stuff,
this in your ass hall.
Now
they blow that smoke because you're like this on the other end and you start
believing it,
man.
You start believing I'm going to to bank crock.
Fuck those dudes up.
I always told that he should make a shirt that says Bangkok ready.
I think he did.
Did he base somebody made a shirt that said,
do you remember that story?
You remember that?
Fascinating.
So I was there.
I was in the locker room and he said he's Bangkok ready.
There's not a better term ever.
Well,
it's not a better ever,
especially when you know the guy's not elite striker and ask about Jesus Christ.
Bangkok.
Ready?
Yeah.
I'd watch them kick the bag and I'd be like,
oh no,
you better take this guy down.
Take this guy down and get y'all strangle on in Australia.
So he's just told fight sage was in Bangkok ready?
Sage was not one championship ready siege.
You know he's an Alpha male now,
right?
Is he still there?
I believe so.
Left Alpha male recently did Lance Palmer relief,
I think Lynn's plumber while ago.
Mark Henry,
who's the chick,
the Badass since Cynthia Kavio.
Yeah,
she would she go,
I don't know
how much progress she left.
She's a bad,
no.
I mean,
I don't know what they're doing over there,
so I can't really comment.
I don't either.
But I do know that when Bang Ludwig was there,
they make it some giant ass fucking progress.
Everybody started moving better.
Everybody started putting together combinations better click.
You need a head coach.
Fighters need a head coach and even then you might not win right now.
It's tough enough.
You need a hot,
you need a head coach.
You need that.
You need a beast.
He looked at,
if I was,
if I was competing,
really,
if I was a young man and I was thinking about fighting and MMA,
I'd probably move to Montreal.
I got to Montreal or I was talking to a Dustin about this at a att.
There's so many guys was you guys in the UFC.
They get there and they were the,
you know,
the big swinging dicks that they're small gym.
They come to att and they're expecting the same attention.
It's problems with two problems with how Florida,
Pussy and Pussy and cocaine.
The cocaine.
I've never tried it and maybe that I've never done it.
That was what I said though.
[inaudible]
of personal resilience.
Woo.
Manish spans Colombian.
She could checks.
That's a reason to go down there,
bro.
You,
Dick is going to be hard.
Every time the wind blows,
you're going to be excited and you're not going to be focusing and you're going
to get cracked.
Yeah,
so maybe New Mexico.
Huh?
Also has hot ass girls.
The other thing about this is I really believe about some camps can have too
many killers and you can get fucked up as you're trying to learn and grow and
you never have enough guys that are,
that you could practice on.
I think Aka because they're so tough.
They've injured each other and I'm like,
I should get fucked.
If I was wanting to learn how to wrestle and I wanted to be like a,
a better wrestler.
France and gotten,
yeah,
I agree.
Because dcs has was funny and Steve Bay left.
Yeah,
he's on his way out.
Canes there.
You already beat him.
Go there,
dude.
That's why I say that's what I say.
Yeah,
he's in France.
But because his fucking striking the power.
Yes.
It's like such a fucking checkmate weapon.
Then no matter what anybody does,
you're always ready for checkmate.
Boom.
It's like wilder,
that kind of ridiculous power.
You're always ready for checkmate.
You're always ready.
Wilders is even more impressive than Francis.
I don't know about that.
Let me tell you something that is amazing.
13 that isn't.
It just has to cut to Marty.
My motherfucking words at Francis in Ghana decides to jump ship and go
heavyweight,
cheerful.
Where are you going with this?
He will knew some fools nukes of water.
Oh well let's kind of take a long time to get to Wilder's level said wow.
As a world champions undefeated yet they say,
but if Francis and got,
look Francis and Ghana not ready to box wilder right now,
but let me tell you some starch in 30 seconds.
He might or he might connect.
No,
he could list against one.
There's not the slickest guy in the world.
We're not talking about Muhammad Ali [inaudible] Olympic level.
Bob Francis knows sort of sort of a year and a half in,
he was in the Olympics,
but he mostly gets by on power and range.
He's Olympics,
Olympics metal,
but it's only a year and a half into boxing.
I mean,
I think France is probably can 12 rounds.
He did.
No,
no,
no doubt about it.
He's amazing.
But if Francis has a problem with grappling,
you think about what he did,
what does he not have a problem with striking?
He kaos owl circles in the UFC.
True.
But Alistair Overeem is a world class striker.
I mean,
he's a kick boxer at the highest level.
When's The k one Grand Prix?
I mean,
he's knocked out Badr Hari.
He's been beaten fucking Turkish Tyson for sure.
He's beaten some good guys.
He's a little older,
a little older.
And this is the other thing.
If Alistair Overeem entered the boxer me with,
without,
with Deontay wilder,
he wouldn't last a minute.
I agree with you.
However,
maybe we'll,
if he kick his legs straight,
buy shorts,
what we're talking about.
But it was in Muay Thai food.
I mean it was an MMA fight,
so he's allowed to do everything.
I'm just saying it straight box and talking about apples and oranges.
Right.
But think about that.
If Deontay wilder fought Allister over him in an MMA fight right now,
how do you think that would go?
He finished him in under a minute.
He like kicked the shit out of Saint [inaudible].
You Ain't need you to take him down and took around three seconds.
But he couldn't do that to Francis and Ghana.
Couldn't leg kick him,
couldn't keep them off him because I wasn't going to May.
But if it's Allister and,
and uh,
Francis wind to the box arena,
they get absolutely annihilate.
I agree with you.
But the thing that's holding,
well,
unless they focused on it for as long as those guys did,
but the thing that holds back Deontay wilder from people,
oh,
like all the boxing pundits praising him is that they think he has awkward
technique.
He's wild,
but his results are spectacular.
Okay.
Frances and Ghana knew everybody.
He connects on other than steepy goes night night.
Steve Bay is the only guy steep,
a CPA,
survived steep pay,
figured out how to use his championship medal and his grit and use his take
downs and won the fight.
Derrick Lewis state some shots.
I was just a terrible fight.
That fight.
I don't even think that counts.
That doesn't count.
That fight is so that's such a mess from top to bottom.
That was the worst fight.
Maybe in the history of the fucking sport.
Agree.
They didn't throw anything,
but the problem with that fight it was because there are such knockout artists
you would expect in such fireworks.
Dude,
it was a big disappointment.
I said to everybody,
there is not a fucking way this fight concise,
and I said,
we can never say that because it always sucks.
I know.
Whenever you say there's not a way this fight can suck,
it's to suck.
So disappointing man.
It was so disappointed.
It was.
But then when he comes back and he knocks out Curtis blades for the second time,
you know,
which I thought great blades had a way better shot at them.
The second me too.
I actually thought he was probably beat him,
especially after the Francis and gone.
Oh fine.
Yes,
but it showed that or the Derrick [inaudible] but it showed them in Ghana is
really got it back together again and that's fight jds.
They moved it though.
It was supposed to be in Vegas.
They moved it.
It's a dangerous fiber.
JDS didn't right for both guys really,
but yeah,
you can do ads.
I just think in Ghana has,
if you're going to stand in front of him,
man,
he's going to hit you or something.
Yeah,
it's a fascinating thing.
He's one of those,
I'm going to hit you with something Kane.
I was like,
holy fuck.
Yeah,
man on his leg blew out her so bad.
He really did think that's what happened.
When you look at the replay,
he clearly got hit with an upper cut,
like a shelf.
There's still like a car when almost taught needs that guy all he needs to touch
you.
I just need to end.
The more he does it,
the more confident he gets in it,
the better.
He's only been fucking training for six years.
Do people want to send in their heads?
See Him verse John.
So bad numbers of John Jones.
Yeah.
What do think would happen?
I think John will tickets.
I think John smoked him.
John would take them down and Jenkinson John easily could be 240 pounds easily
just go.
I think what he's doing is he's going to clean out light heavyweight.
There's really no one there for him.
He's gonna clean that out and then go to heavyweight.
Maybe he's in it or maybe he just stays at light heavyweight and just goes down
as the goat and just keeps beating up on them.
All the contenders.
It's where to be.
DC wants that fight again at light heavyweight,
like come on,
do it.
At least that heavyweight
heavyweights,
the way to go,
it's an ego thing for DCC gets passed steep a,
which is a big f.
Realize like DC DC connected with that beautiful punch in the clench,
but Steve Bay has had over a year to stew on that.
It's been driving him.
Fuck.
I don't think that's a good thing.
I think it's good for Steve.
Steve is an animal.
I'm not.
I'm not worried about that.
I think he's going to be better.
I think green routes in issue.
I don't think so.
DC's been way more active,
but Steve pays a real veteran man.
He's a real veteran and he's a crumbled dudes,
a hard ass.
He's not going to come in there with a lot of expectations on himself.
He's just going to do his best,
I think.
I'm not worried at all about the a tougher fight for DC.
Look,
if Donald Cerrone was taking a year plus off and then we kind of fight for the
title,
I'll be like,
Ooh,
I'd like Donald to get a fight in God.
I wish she would do that.
You and I are off on this.
I wished Donald would take a fucking break and not fight Tony and a three days'
notice.
No,
I agree with that too.
I wish you would take a break and not fight Tony in three weeks notice,
but three weeks after his last fight,
but when Donald fights a lot,
as long as the best on reason,
it's the best.
Donald.
That's what he wants.
Yes.
He's just,
Oh,
I used to get in the groove.
He likes to stay active,
I think for steep be champion and do that though.
Named Sonia who's done it go named one guy.
Well,
everyone's different.
I'm not,
I'm just,
I'm just going off who measurements?
There's no one who's that?
Who's ever fought like the multimers champion,
who's fought the most,
the most like the most like active champion.
Most DC's pretty active at light heavyweight and heavyweight.
Pretty fucking act.
Pretty fucking active.
And I think John is trying to be really active.
I mean think about whole divisions.
Fuck yeah,
he's,
he's going to clear out all those dip out and leave them like the fucking queen
of the dragons.
Okay.
George Saint Pierre Fought 15 title bouts.
Wow.
He had 15 title.
That's crazy.
Radio tour 15 how about Randy coture,
but that doesn't mean that all these years later,
still in 15 over seven years,
that's still all those years later.
Randy coast tour is still tied for the record of the most title fights.
That's crazy.
Mighty mouse right under that with 14 Anderson 13 the differences with all those
guys,
you know,
I mean it's all different eras,
different divisions.
Jeremy did everything because I think what John's doing,
the current era is more impressive.
I'm like Randy or George or any Anderson did.
Who Do you think is a danger to John Right now?
There's no one at light heavyweight.
Yeah,
no one,
absolutely no one Thiago Santos.
I know we got a hypen and be like,
oh,
puncher's chance.
Yeah,
for sure.
I get that.
There's no one at light heavyweight.
Maybe you don't want Johnny Walker,
but he's so far removed right now.
He has to get by maybe three more guys before we start and being like,
hey,
you might be a threat,
but he's maybe a potential hope.
His shoulders.
Okay.
If his shoulders,
okay.
What that guy does is crazy.
He starts his people.
He stocked starts Kahleel Roundtree with an elbow in the clinch.
I remember that.
Yeah.
Standing wishes that crazy.
This kind of Elisha,
one of them bad boys.
Vicious Kaos him with that.
And then chaos.
Misha,
Sir Chernoff with a flying knee,
right to the fucking chops freak.
He's a freak,
but he hasn't done it like John has to show gun who uh,
to function.
No comparison with Cheetah.
I mean,
there's no comparison to anyone who's ever fought in the light heavyweight
division and Jon Jones right now,
there's no comparison.
There's no threats,
but except DC.
But DC lost the lost twice.
Not a threat at light heavyweight DC.
I still be ways as red light,
heavy weight.
I think he's a threat.
Not heavyweight.
Yes.
Heavyweight.
He's a threat is power goes up.
We've seen how it works out for DC if DC got more dedicated and disciplined with
his diet and said,
what if DC fights against DPA and says,
so when is this deep a fight happen?
Is it July?
July?
Okay.
So what if a DC says,
okay,
August,
September,
let's,
let's plan for New Year's Eve with Jon Jones that weekend and he takes a week
off.
It goes to fucking Mardi gras or whatever the fucking wants to do.
Drink some drinks and beer shadows in New Orleans.
Yeah.
Have some pizza kicks back.
And then goes on a serious diet with a real good nutritionist who's gonna check
his macros,
make sure he's eating healthy food.
You think that's why he's not being John?
No,
but I'm saying where he could get down to two oh five healthy where he doesn't
have any look.
Daniel Cormier,
if there's anything has ever held him back.
He's,
he's not the best at his diet and within swarms DC.
Great.
Well,
he's one of the things that makes them great.
He's a wrestler.
He's a fantastic rest,
so that makes them great.
He's time shit that makes him great.
He's got his intelligence,
his great,
incredible [inaudible] fat.
I don't know about all that.
That's some people say,
think about that.
Think about the most shredded guys in the UFC.
Well,
I don't mean he should get shredded.
What I mean is she,
he should make two oh five with no problems where he could go to war for five
rounds with a guy like Jon Jones without weakening him.
I Dunno if that's possible.
You might be right.
I don't know if it's in his DNA,
especially I've had to a 40 years of age.
She can't be with the way to go.
I think heavyweight,
his powers up,
we saw that with Steve Bay.
I think if he,
and he's going to connect what she has in the clinch against John,
the power's there,
the the the,
I still think he'll be an underdog,
but that that gap narrows that heavyweight and light heavy weight.
It doesn't switch it at his age.
I think it's even further apart now that John's being more active.
Well maybe he wants to do that to prove a point because that's the piece.
John Heavyweight Tillman,
light heavyweight and heavyweight dude,
you're the champ John.
If he wants to have that likes,
he fight that rubber match.
Go with,
even though he's two and I'll go there and let's see what happens now.
Now that I'm thinking about it,
I kind of agree with,
especially for DC,
it's like DC dude.
If you beat John at heavyweight and you ride off into the sunset game,
set match,
best of all time to ever do it.
Like how about this?
Tito Ortiz right now owns chocolate dough,
right?
Chocolate.
Dell smashes him two times when they're in their prime,
but then Tito knocked him out and chuck looked terrible.
Tito code him.
It looked really bad and tuck will never fight again and Tito will always sleep
at night knowing he just fucked chuck Liddell up.
Does just think about those other ones.
You don't even think about it.
He got it back.
He got it back in a big way.
DC,
we got it back the way you want it to clipped him with a right hand and put his
lights out and then punched him a couple times when he's out and that's a replay
and for and for DC it's like he,
even after the John Loss,
he went on deaf fucking heavyweight to knock out steep at who some can argue
it's the best UFC heavy weight of the time he went on to beat Derrick Lewis who
so dangerous.
And then you've,
unless say Pete,
Steve Bay for a second time,
what the fuck?
You know?
You know what I was really impressed with?
I was really impressed with the way chuck handled that last.
Did you see the way chuck talked about it on an Instagram,
he just basically said,
you know,
hey man,
you know you,
you put yourself out there,
you go out there and you set goals,
you know you,
you try and if you fail it doesn't,
doesn't mean you quit.
You get back on your horse and you can get right back to it.
I try not to be so judgmental,
let go of all the handouts,
all the bullshit.
I was very impressed.
Me Too.
And I liked chuck.
He's a good person.
I check if Tito's or rather John John's number one,
Chuck's number two as far as light heavyweights,
great light heavyweights.
He's,
he was a fucking man.
I mean he was,
when he defined the early days of the UFC,
one of the things about the UFC was like this crazy thing was like cage fighting
and here's this guy with painted toenails in a Mohawk
and I'm Ted Tattoo and he's just murking people.
Merkin people.
Biggest like was like the first big,
Big Star in the sport and goes,
go on to entourage and have commercials.
Don't fucking automotive commercial.
It was like a rock star too.
I mean that dude went hall.
Where do you stand to?
Remember that one interview that he did where he was hammered.
He was on something.
He was on all the drugs,
everything.
And he's like doing morning TV.
He's like,
yeah,
I'd like to fight the hall.
She was real in that gray.
I love that too.
What the fuck he said,
but he was clearly on cloud nine like he's an animal man,
like a legit won't do you stand on letting those,
whose responsibility is that?
The guys like Bj Penn.
It keeps losing.
It's defined his leg,
his snout guy like Anderson Silva.
Where do you stand on letting those guys fight?
It's a very good question.
If you're Dana White,
what do you do?
Because at the end of the day,
only do submissions can go all physically.
Yeah,
man,
he passed the fucking physical so we gotta let them fight.
But at the end of the day,
if they don't have a resource or a job from the head,
man,
if Dana calls Bj or chuck just like you did chuck,
he's like,
I'm not giving you a venue to find that it's not happening.
So I wonder at what point,
if your day,
now,
let's say your data,
at what point do you tell these guys stop fighting?
Because I feel like for Anderson,
although I don't remember him that way,
the new generations remember him for being this guy for Bj.
The new generation only knows him as losing.
We know him as one of the greats.
So I feel like here's my [inaudible] to say you can't fight anymore.
I don't know.
Bj is capable of competing at the level that he's competing at right now when
he's losing to these guys.
I don't know if he is because it doesn't seem like he's capable of it wastes
last what,
six in a row.
Yeah.
And if I looked at the Bj that I saw against Ryan Hall up until the time he gets
leg locked,
he looks fucking great.
That after that happened fast though,
bro.
No,
I know.
I'm with you.
I'm saying he looks like he's fit.
He looks like he's in shape.
He looks like he's a top fighter,
but
he almost needs to fight a young guy coming up so we could see when he fights
Clegg Weda or you find someone like that.
It's almost losing.
And then Ryan,
Holly's losing.
I feel like,
I don't know.
He's not who he used to be.
No,
obviously not.
But I don't even know where his heads.
I feel like if I'm,
if I'm Dana,
I'm going,
hey man,
I'm doing you guys a solid.
You can't fight here anymore.
And now they might go on to other organizations,
but it's not the UFC.
So they can go on there and compete.
But you're not going to tarnish your legacy at the highest level here in the
UFC?
Not under my watch,
no.
So I it,
I couldn't do it.
I was like,
I'll never pick against Bj.
I would never pick against Randy couture.
I just,
I don't have it in me.
So when Bj fights,
I'm like,
Oh,
I'll take PJ because I refused to pick against and that's how much I respect
them.
But at some point I not gonna do it and I don't honestly Danna can either.
Could you be like,
hey dude,
no more.
We're done.
Well,
I'd have to be friends with them like I was friends with you.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean,
when,
when Rodriguez three 60
roundhouse kicked him in the face,
that should've been the end.
I mean,
uh,
well that was a,
you saw that and compare to Bj when Bj beat Sean Sherk like you're looking at a,
this is a severely different fighter whose job,
family and friends,
no one's job.
You know,
here's the thing,
man.
We can't let the fighter besides,
well,
what is,
I don't think he should be competing at the highest level,
the sport.
But if he still wants to compete,
like who's to say Kent?
Who is to say you can't go to a small organization and fight for them?
Clues to say.
I mean,
he's not choices it Justin,
he's not getting sparked out,
you know,
I mean,
he's still conscious.
He's not,
yeah,
I know he's getting beat,
but it's not getting crushed help and not all the fights at least,
I mean the Ryan Hall one is probably like the most,
um,
Brian Hall skin tear.
Anyone's in the off though.
Hey,
I can tell you.
Oh yeah,
if you get,
if they give him anybody's going to do that to your knee.
Well,
he's a phenomenal grappler and it's super,
super intelligent guy too.
But um,
that was probably the kindest way for him to lose,
just to get tapped real quick rather than just get a black belt beat up like
Frankie Edgar did to him,
you know?
But I guess maybe again,
the commission,
they have a tough job because like physically we can't seem to his brain,
but physically he's passing all the tests.
Like who you tell Bernard Hopkins I take that last fight when he got knocked out
of the fucking ring,
whose job was to tell Roy Jones,
don't go to rush and get knocked out.
Yeah,
that's a story that's so old.
So it repeats itself.
These guys that were,
they got,
that's what makes these stories so great when they're in their prime and you're
watching on the come up and so special.
But it's also what makes this sport so fucking heartbreaking because you know
who does do that?
The NFL and the NBA,
they tell,
you know,
they tell you now that's it.
And it's very black and white.
That's because someone has to fill that position and they're not about nostalgia
there about who does the best job in that position.
Shouldn't the UFC be that way?
But it's not that the UFC doesn't know who does the best job in that position
until they set you up with somebody.
When they see over and over and over again,
then we've saw when again,
the yardsticks.
But the argument is he's not getting crushed.
It's not getting sparked out and not getting knocked out.
He just not as good as it used to be.
No,
it's not a good argument,
but he's not,
he's not as good as you used to be it.
And I'm not saying that I'm not arguing.
Why do you think it's still at the UFC?
Um,
why was it fashion?
I don't know why the cause he's still a draw.
Maybe that's a good question because right now the respect,
is it out of respect?
Like what is it,
what he's done for the game.
He's earned the right to go out on his own note.
But the,
the,
the stakes are so high in fighting.
It's different than basketball.
I don't know whose job,
but it's not,
I don't have the answer and I wish I did.
I don't know.
It's a,
it's the most heartbreaking thing in sports I think.
I agree.
And I think with Bj,
if he would have found,
and I,
I don't know Bj well enough,
but a few would have found a passion like I did with standup or podcasting or
something else.
You probably would have been out and never come back maybe.
But the thrill of what makes Bj yeah,
I mean he's a multiple time world champion.
The thrill of Bj when he was in his prime.
It's probably indescribable.
Like what brings Nate Diaz back?
Even though he has money in the bank,
what's going to bring Connor back?
Yeah.
It's not money.
Those guys were born fighter.
They're natural born fighter.
This is what they do and that's,
that's what makes them feel alive.
So I dunno.
Yeah.
The excitement and the thrill.
The fucking,
I mean,
and look,
we're all going to die.
Sorry.
You,
when people say you should look out for their health,
well then we should stop fighting all together.
Correct.
And stop playing football.
Yeah.
Stopped doing.
I stopped drinking and no more driving.
Yeah.
Driving is dangerous.
Go walk everywhere.
If we just walk and people getting accidents walking,
they'll be fine.
They'll bump into each other's.
Yeah.
Big Deal.
That would be cool.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
there's a real argument for that,
right?
Like this is this.
Do you have a small window?
The experience,
this life doing what you want.
But yeah,
with a guy like Bj Penn,
the reality is there's probably be a number of fights that you lose in the UFC
where you can just get cut.
He used to be three.
Was it assigned in paper thing?
No,
but man,
when you've lost two,
which I did that third one,
Joe Silva would tell your manager and he told my manager like,
McMann Lex McMahon goes together with this one.
You know,
it's,
it's probably over.
No,
he wouldn't say that.
He'd go wood,
we're giving them one more and he knew that was like,
that was your shot.
If you lost,
you're done.
Even if you won by decision,
they wouldn't cut you.
You knew if as long as you got the job done,
you extent,
I saw one of your interviews is really interesting.
You're talking about,
um,
if you bomb,
you could always go tell him the Improv and have a new set redeem yourself.
But when you're fighting,
if you lost,
you'd have like six months.
Yeah.
Per Worse.
It just dwell on that and Jay and be like,
no,
I promise you I'm getting better and stand up and be like not,
I promised I bombed with the gum store.
I went to the problem.
They laughed.
So what's up?
What's up?
Yeah.
The,
the life of a fighter is probably the most stressful job in all sports and
certainly in all of entertainment besides,
you know,
obviously when we're at war and soldiers it's close thing and get to spark.
Yes,
and I do not,
I don't admire it.
I feel sorry for them because I've been through it,
but that's from my perspective,
a lot of those guys,
they,
they fucking live off that man.
I watch and I'm like,
well,
you're guys.
Yeah,
I'm too nice.
I felt horrible for Brazil.
I felt bad for wild or when he got down like,
God,
he's such a good dude.
I wish you would find something else to do.
You didn't tell us till the show time guys.
I'm like,
God parlays this into something really cool.
After this,
he can make hundreds of millions of dollars.
I think Deontae $20 million that night.
Yeah.
He's going to go down as one of the greatest of all time.
I think so.
I think he's,
he's getting better with every fight and I think of Joshua gets hit on the chin
with one of those fucking bombs away.
We can see some crazy shit thinking about wow.
There is,
he knows how to take it to,
he could take it.
He got blasted by Ortiz.
If you're noticing the Brazil fight,
he got caught.
He backs up,
he got blast against fury.
Yup.
He gets hit.
He got hit in the 12th round against fury.
Josh are so interesting.
Oh yeah.
Cause Joshua cracks.
Oh he does.
He does.
And he's been hit before and I dropped,
I didn't find her view.
Latimer Klitschko yeah,
for that fight.
And he got back off the ground and starched them.
I did this interview with a Fox
sports,
uh,
Lee.
Hey.
And uh,
she goes,
who's the most overrated?
A mainstream boxer.
And I answered,
I'm like,
hmm,
I'm going to say Anthony Joshua.
Just cause I want him to hear this.
And he's like,
Oh fuck down in a fight.
Wild are now.
But people ran with,
it was like,
oh,
he thinks Joshua was overrated.
No,
I don't think Joe,
I think Joshua is such a fucking gold medalist.
Overrated.
Now he's being girls.
What do you take?
These don't make sense.
Amazed.
I just want him in wild fight.
He's also built like a Greek God.
You know,
it might be a six man alive.
You might be.
It's fun.
He's talked at like two 45 jasper shredded and you heard him commentate.
Yeah,
he's brilliant ticket and that accent.
It's lovely.
Lovely champ.
If as gay it'd be so on.
Let's go champ.
It'd be so on.
Yeah.
Um,
what is happening with my man,
Chan,
the cannons bank of the legs.
Let's go champ.
He's been trying to get a fight forever as he still,
yeah,
he's always trying to get a fight.
Yeah.
He's those too old and it's like,
too much of a risk is man horse race.
You know,
he's skew horseman.
Yeah.
If you're not those three,
no one will see fight anybody.
Yeah.
And you would have to be moving him up to line was too old to hear Jim gray
after the fight.
What he said,
he goes,
the wilder he goes and people were booing him because he goes,
I get,
and I,
I love it,
but I also get why people are booing.
He goes,
he goes,
champ,
louder.
Great performance because I hate to tell you in Brazil's behind him,
he goes,
no one wants to see you do is to Brazil.
No one wants to fight or tease next.
That's supposedly what was supposed to be next.
I want to see fight or t's next.
It's either Joshua or fury.
That's all we want to see.
What are we going to get that the crowd,
which is Brazil got starts.
I'm like,
come on,
he's in the ring.
But Jim,
Greg is no fence.
So they were booing Jim gray when he said that.
He asked that.
But,
but I'm,
I'm like,
I've been shouting from the rooftops and my podcasts in the exact same thing.
It's hard.
And I,
and I told showtime this,
it's hard to sell these fights because no one cares unless it's the ones we want
to see,
which is why what's makes the UFC so great?
You know,
you're gonna get one versus the champ,
you know,
to get the number two guy versus the champ.
The best are fighting the best night in,
night out.
Yeah.
So they got mad at a Jim Gray for telling the truth.
She going to get mad.
That's just,
that is what it is.
Jim Gray knows what the fuck [inaudible] on the truth.
It's the truth.
He knows what the fuck he's doing.
Look,
man,
I'm all,
I want to see Louis Ortiz.
I want to see that fight.
You want to see what Louis Rdcs in wilder again,
100% you'd rather you think that should be next?
No,
I'm not saying that should be next.
I look if t j if Joshua and Tyson fury decided to fight and Louis decides to
fight a wilder,
I'm fine with that.
You want to see it again?
I'm fine.
I'm fine with that.
Who sort is a beast?
He's a beast.
Not,
it's not the best fight,
but I would watch the shit out of that fight more than Dominic Brazil.
Oh,
for sure.
I would love to see that fight.
I would've loved to see that fight instead,
and I think they offered a toward teas,
but I think Ortiz had an injury.
Daft or tease Joshua,
because Joshua was June,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
To offer it to him and he said,
no,
he wasn't here,
but this is,
this is boxing his man.
It goes,
we want more money in that one.
Double Joshua's team went on short notice.
Now we're,
we're giving you,
I think it was 5 million.
He went 10.
Oh look,
Lewis were teases Lee jet Bro.
Lead Shit.
He's a fucking cubic Olympic limpic box or no idea how old he is,
but to come on,
how bad asses.
Goddamn.
Deontay wilder.
I mean he's,
you know,
house full or teases.
Yes.
Any cracks.
Somebody's house.
He hits so fucking hard.
So does Ortiz.
No,
he does not.
Tease is a killer killer,
but he is not a killer.
The way 90 while there is,
that's a totally different jobs.
Fury on a killer like water.
When it comes to one punch power,
dude,
why is it in the world?
Wilder is made out of wood.
That dude is iron.
When he,
when he fucking hits dudes,
he hits dudes in a different way.
It's like the getting clubbed.
Boom.
No,
he says it's amazing,
dude.
The first thing I asked him what he did the podcast.
I'm like,
how the fuck do you hit so hard?
Like look,
he just knows he can.
He can absorb shots.
He's just smart enough to hang on there and just stand in front of you.
If you're standing in front of him,
he can.
Uncork kidding.
He is 17 pounds.
This is a tough fight.
This is what I'm saying is losing this fight.
Dude,
look at this.
He's getting his body worked.
He's getting beat.
His wife got club there too and he is getting fucking hurt so this is not,
this is not an easy fight for him and I think the rematch will be even harder.
I really truly believe that.
I think whatever Ortiz has got left in his body,
he's going to come at them and Deontay wilder knows that this guy could fucking
box.
The difference I think is with wilder.
You're dealing with a guy who is getting better with every fight because he's
literally learning on the job as one of the most successful heavyweight
champions of all time because he's only been fighting since he was 20 he's
getting better and better and better for loose all t's.
Louis Ortiz is like maintaining right now,
60 years,
49,000 years old years old from Cuba.
We have no,
he has 70,000 flights.
He's only lost once.
It's still wilder.
He's been popped.
He's been popped for Stoikos Josias.
It's fucking fury or Joshua,
go fuck your mother.
And then he dropped him and he dropped him here.
I know.
This is where it moves into the Joshua Wilder next.
Listen Bro,
if we don't,
I'm telling you I am down to see this fight again.
I'm down to see this fight again or teas.
Oh,
he hurt.
Wow Man.
Wow.
This isn't that fun.
Yup.
He hurt.
Wilder does the happiest.
That dude,
I fucking,
I lost that job.
I love that guy.
I love his story.
I love how he is as a person.
He's fun person.
He's great.
And his also,
it's interesting how small he is as a heavyweight,
so thin when he fought Tyson fury way two oh nine it's nuts,
man.
Two Oh nine my favorite part is he's such a beast of a debt to bring this kid.
He was a baby,
brings him in,
his wife everywhere,
thinks the rest of the kids everywhere.
Like I was surprised how sweet he was.
Like he's like a warm friendly guy.
You love him.
Right?
His blessings to everybody and blessing his blessing talent,
man.
Yeah,
like vibrates.
Yes.
This is the real deal,
man.
I'm get to be around.
I'm,
I'm excited about the heavyweight division two because I feel the same way about
Joshua.
Joshua seems like a chore like Champ of a Person I've ever talked to him seems
awesome and we get all these interviews he like comes across,
he's smiling and he's charismatic and he's interested in probably got one of
them.
Land Rover v Eights defenders,
just fine the girls.
I'm saying that because I saw a video of him where there was a car show where
they drove Anthony Joshua around.
He got to drive around one of those a land rover defenders,
those box.
He looked military vehicles.
I lizard her though.
They're about to release a new one.
They're coming out with a new one.
Yeah.
Land roads coming out with a new defender.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
They have a new model since there's such hits.
Just like Ford's come out with a bronco.
Yeah.
They're coming out with a bronco and they're also going to have like a smaller
Bronco just uh,
took the baby bronco or a two door in a four door and wait til they do like this
VT version of the raptor vision of the Bronx.
Shit.
Get rid of the rafters,
your rafters.
One of my all time favorite trucks.
It is such a meat head move to get a goddamn rafter.
Especially in such a meathead like you've got bales of Hay back there son.
What are you using that pickup?
Four zero thing.
What am I using for being awesome.
Being awesome.
Yeah.
The thing about those tools lifted with fucking monster truck raptors are
preposterous cars cause they give someone the ability to drive like a real off
road vehicle with 500 plus horsepower and just get it from a factory and has a
craziest suspension.
You could just drive over the fucking moon with [inaudible] pension.
I mean it has a crazy travel in those wheels.
So when you drive it on the highway too,
it's like smooth cause it feels like an s class almost absorbs everything but
yet it's huge.
Yeah.
It's a monster of a vehicle and you could accessory the fuck out of that bitch
with some crazy bumpers and rear bumpers.
Tail bumpers.
Sure.
Side pipes.
I mean sidesteps and shit.
What does that Deontay Wilder Gatorskin oh no.
Oh No.
Let's go champ.
No,
I don't support this.
I said,
Hey,
I love him more now.
No.
Oh I want more pictures.
Yeah.
What are you gonna do with gaps?
Listen,
first of all,
that's a wrap.
Okay.
That's not really asking.
It's a wrap.
What if it was real gatorskin they would have to glue it to the cop and the on
it you,
there's like divots on the little things
hush your mouth.
That's not August.
Did I have an alligator skin?
I hate alligators.
I don't know if you know this.
I don't like him.
I don't,
I don't talk about it too much,
but I have like a hate fear.
Scared of them.
Yeah.
When I was a little kid,
I lived in Florida when I live in Gainesville from age 11 to 13 and we live near
a place called Lake Alice and Lake Alice had alligators and I knew there was a
lady that was walking her out,
her and walking her Haugen,
walking her dog by the lake and the algorithm came out and snatched her fucking
dog and I didn't see it.
I didn't see it.
But I remember that being a thing and I remember seeing those goddamn things all
the time and everybody telling me that you don't have to worry about it.
When I'm 11,
my,
my sister,
my sister is 10 and we'd be hanging out this lake and I'd be like,
what the fuck is to stop an alligator from eating us?
Nothing.
And I real,
I,
and I remember looking them in the eye and I'm fascinated by them.
Right?
They're amazing.
Cause I always love dinosaurs.
When I was a kid that was a sore.
It is a dinosaur.
And I'm just always in a nature,
I'm always into to cool nature of shows and documentaries.
So I'm looking at this thing thinking like,
oh,
we're just used to them being around.
Like we shouldn't allow them to be around.
We're just used to them being around.
So we think it's cool that they're around,
but they will fucking eat,
you know,
eat your Doni chance they get.
So I started buying,
I buy a alligator.
I always have alligator always add.
All my belts are always alligator.
That's gangster,
dude.
I have alligator,
um,
bags from my pool cues.
I'm been alligator alligator,
which like alligators.
I have an alligator wallet.
If I told you I did dude,
I don't like them or to kill them.
Oh Wow.
I want to kill them.
If alligators,
if there's too many of them and they were near you,
you'd want to kill them too.
They're eating machines.
They're heartless eating machines.
They got a brain the size of a thumb.
I don't like him,
dude.
How about the one at Disneyworld?
The parents that their kid,
they're the two year old.
Yes.
Eight.
The fucking kid.
They had no,
at Disney world,
they have a real problem in Florida.
They have to scan the fucking property looking for alligators.
They have to go through it.
They've waters there.
I took my daughter,
my youngest,
we went fishing there.
There's a,
there's a,
there's a lake that where he'd go bass fishing.
It's amazing.
There's grades of alligators in there.
Fuck.
Gather is,
you've gotta be careful,
man.
Anytime you've got a body of water and land around Florida.
Yeah.
No swimming in Florida.
That's my role.
No swim in those lakes swimming.
No.
Any row.
Don't know swimming.
So there's no water.
Schwartz in Florida.
That's the rule in out of the water.
No,
I sent Tampa.
They're going to go to the beach.
No,
fuck you.
Fuck you and your saltwater crush sharks.
Sharks.
You got shark soup down here,
bitch.
Fuck that.
Fuck this.
You tell me ways to die in Florida.
Dude.
The craziest thing is happening right now in the everglades is the pythons.
They said that there has been a 90 plus percent decrease in the amount of
rabbits,
possums,
raccoons,
deer.
Like all the major mammals that live in the Florida everglades are gone.
They've all been killed by python.
God,
they took a Judas Python.
You know what a Judas Python is?
They take a python,
they put a chip in it so they can track it.
So they had this male python and they sent him out there to find the females,
and they used him to locate through the,
you know,
using the gps to locate a 16 foot python,
16 foot female python that was pregnant.
Came,
set,
match.
Yeah.
So he's banging these bitches out there,
make it,
I'm pregnant and he's homeless or lunch and these evil fucking snakes look at
that thing.
Is that it?
Stake hold stakes boyfriend?
They have to kill it.
Hands off.
No,
no,
no.
They're,
they're invasive.
They're not supposed to be.
It had 73 eggs to me it was more than 17 feet long.
You imagined stumbling across that thing.
You're dead.
That thing weighs as much as you do.
Holy Fuck.
Yeah.
That's probably a 200 pound snake.
Oh my God.
Says that this little bitch ass hundred 4,440 and getting away from that,
I get in my face if I got the knife.
So he a snake on the live.
He's so hard.
God Pay.
Let's wrap this up.
All right.
Um,
people want to see your special,
they can watch it on showtime.
Yeah,
you can.
you can watch it for free.
Go to showtime.com get 30 days of showtime for free.
Go to showtime.com promocode Chubb.
You can watch it for free,
for free.
And um,
you've got to do some more of those improv shows.
I've got a bunch coming up.
Tell [inaudible] let me do it better.
Those,
I want to say thank you to you though,
bro.
I wouldn't have even been on this journey if it wasn't for you,
man.
Dude,
I'm proud of that.
I love you.
I love you too,
brother.
I'm very,
very happy for my friends.
Bye.
See Ya.